so
so
foreign
so
the microphone guys we are back my
goodness
welcome thank you all you know i when i
see the chat flying i know something's
up
it's a live stream so you know there
might be some technical difficulties
welcome back everybody we're doing it
like i was saying when i was a kid we
did saturday morning
cartoons now we're doing saturday
morning 3d live streams guys thanks for
joining me if you can hear me if you can
see me
give me that thumbs up guys thank you so
much this is going to be a
very very exciting stream man i put like
a solid day or two into figuring out how
to
how to get this uh himalayan salt rock
texture to look
right we're gonna we're gonna jump into
this um
pretty soon here but man it's i'm very
proud of how this turned out it's all uh
you know mostly minus the rock texture
which we're gonna switch out for some
noise
it's all pbr so um very very cool stuff
i want to walk you guys through my
process it's a pretty uh
you know it's it's not that difficult
it's not that difficult it's just this
little setup here if you guys are using
blender
um follow along with me it's gonna be
fun i promise
so yeah we're gonna build out this
himalayan salt rock texture from what i
have what i just showed you guys
and i'm gonna try and make it even
better here on the live stream for you
guys so
i'm very excited thank you hey for all
of you guys who are joining for the
first time
welcome it's good to see you guys um and
for all of you guys who are returning
thank you for coming back thanks for
joining me on a saturday and learning
with me guys the whole point of this
channel right now is to learn
and grow together in our passions
and creative endeavors so before we get
into it guys
um i got a uh a very exciting
a very exciting little uh little company
that
that hit me up and i've worked with them
twice now this is the second time
they're super cool
and i think that they can help you guys
out if you don't have a super computer
if you need to find a computer a cloud
computer perhaps
to get some renders going so we're gonna
take a look at uh
the the sponsor today and we're gonna
hop into it guys
let's do it today's live stream is
brought to you by wagon.io
who provides personal cloud computers
that can run any software
at varying levels of computing power for
artists just like you guys
baggins had some really cool upgrades
since the last time i showed them off so
let me show you guys all the cool new
stuff first off if you guys use the
promo code of veganfriends21
you'll get free usage for all their
different options here you can quickly
select the programs
you'd like to pre-install on your bag
and computer and if your program of
choice isn't here don't worry it can be
downloaded once you boot your bag and pc
from here you guys are met with your
personal dashboard where you can choose
which computer you'd like to boot
let's go ahead and select the cheapest
performance option it's called
planet boom let's run this bad boy once
you guys connect you can see that our
pre-selected software is downloaded and
ready to use
but do not stop here download and
install whatever you guys want
for your projects this computer is yours
and yours alone
it's freaking awesome so how do you get
your personal files onto your wagon
computer
let me show you guys how easy they've
made this let's go back to the dashboard
to access the files tab on the left
here we can drag and drop files from our
personal computer click send to wagon
and we're good to go even if your
bagging computer isn't running
so let's hop back in and take a look and
our files
are in the files folder ready to use or
if you guys would prefer to just drag
and drop
straight from your pc to your background
desktop that's possible too
now let's go ahead and open this file
and make some adjustments
you guys might recognize this model from
one of my previous videos let's go ahead
and duplicate it a couple times here
let's get some new colors on these guys
too so from here
i'll save shut down and render this from
the beefiest computer
that vegan has they call it galaxy
this thing is super quick it's got 48
cores four graphics cards with 16
gigabytes of vram
and gigabytes of ram
now let's run this computer and open up
our c4d file
from here all we have to do is hit
render
sweet it's looking super nice i'm really
happy with this
so let's navigate to our vegan desktop
and send it to our personal computer
and it's as easy as that guys seamless
integration between your computer
and all of theirs so if you guys want to
get started with your first
super computer or want to supplement
your current pc
this is the best option i can possibly
think of
so get your free cloud computer by going
to vegan.io
and using the vegan friends 21 promo
code to get started
guys so shout outs to vegan for hooking
it up on the stream and yes
one of y'all noticed i try to work with
companies that are relevant to you guys
that can help you all out
on your cg journey so shout outs to
vegan they're really cool they provide a
really cool service so definitely click
that link
in the description below get that free
trial of vegan and uh
get a get a super computer going um it's
it's pretty sweet give it a shot
it's really fun so guys we're gonna jump
into it here
um we have a himalayan
salt rock texture i got two on my desk
all right
um i got two on the side of me here and
they
are it's tough it was tough
this took me some time to figure out how
to do and i'm very excited to break it
down for you guys and
and show you what i learned we're going
to do most of this with um
with noise and i'm using a rocket
displacement texture
same for the normal map here i'm
specifically rd textures to get this
look
but we're going to try and switch it out
with some noise later once we get to the
once we build it up to this point
but you guys can probably go to
ccxerotexters.com or texturehaven.com
and download um like a rock texture grab
the displacement map grab the normal map
and let me start from scratch right from
the beginning with you guys all right so
i'm going to save this if i need to come
back to this project file i'm going to
reference it but
you know it's it's there's a lot going
on it looks like a lot
um but we're going to make this easy for
you all all right
so let's just for again
let let's actually talk about what we
want to hit little steps that we want to
hit here
and i'll show you guys kind of briefly a
brief overview of this thing here
let's render region
and boom boom boom
so what makes this himalayan salt rock
texture special
and and difficult is a few things
first off it's the way the light is
being bounced around the inside of this
thing i'm actually using like a glass
texture
um with uh with like a medium inside so
think of it as like a
it's filled with like fog or filled with
gas or something and it's colored to
look this way and
inside is also a light just like my
lamps here on the side of me
they have a little tiny light on the
inside so i'm using that light to kind
of
boost up and get you that glowing look
you also have like the crystallized
white um
surface to it you know it's not all just
like this opaque
rock it's actually um you know it has
like that
white crystal crystal layer to it so
that's being distributed across this
thing in a specific way as well
and the one thing that i want to do to
this to take it to the next level is
actually when i turn the light off
turn the light off here you can see that
it still
maintains that color that pinkish orange
color
um but what i want to do is when the
light turns on
the white areas those like crystallized
areas i want it to
turn them dark because basically when i
turn on my himalayan salt rock lamp
it turns these white areas right here it
kind of backlights them and the
the light is brighter than that crystal
surface and it turns them dark
and also on the inside you can see like
little details like little pieces of
rock on the inside
that i want to add to this to make it
better so
um let's uh let's save this i'm just
going to
jump right in to a brand new project
file
and make this with you guys okay so the
first thing i start
with is always a figure because i want
to know how big this thing's going to be
and let's build a base real quick so i
have a cylinder
and let's just go ahead and make it
editable
you can hit nb to bring up your
wireframe view and let's just go ahead
and hit
t and crunch this thing down and
scale it down to about there that's like
the little pedestal so we know that that
is
our our base piece let's go ahead and
add
a bevel to it so i'm holding shift and
i'm going to use the bevel deformer
and just kind of adjust this a little
bit maybe point
two or something with three subdivisions
point three with three subdivisions yeah
that that feels fine
um it's a little uh low poly
so one thing we can probably do to fix
that is just throw it into a subdivision
service
and there you go it's it yeah it's
it's quick i'm doing it quick here um
let's make it editable because why not
so hit c and then let's do
let's see let's move the gizmo down so
we can get it right on the ground i'm
going to use the axis center tool drop
the y
all the way down and just zero out the y
again so it's sitting right on the
ground there if we had a
plane it's perfectly on the ground all
right so
we want to build basically a
low poly version of this of this rock
salt lamp so if i were to turn this off
you guys can see um
where is it yeah i kind of baked this
down a little bit but let's start with
the low poly version and then we'll go
from there okay
come on c4d let's go yeah all right so
i'm gonna start
with a another cylinder we'll scale it
down
and i'll give it like you know eight
sides or something
rotational segments eight rotational
segments
and we're gonna just build out the
surface for
us to put our rock texture onto
we don't need any height segments we can
add those are
on our own we'll scale this down and
just kind of sit it right here
let's go ahead and widen this thing out
just a bit
maybe something like like that
and we'll scale it up a touch sit it
right down
c to make it editable let's make some
cuts
i'm hitting ul
kl rather i'm hitting kl to get this
loop cut
going here and i just wanna you know ul
for loop selection
we can scale this down or rather let's
grab
these polygons up here and we'll scale
these guys down
and we can get these guys coming up here
we'll scale these guys down so this is
like your basic
kind of salt rock salt lamp look
my lamps in particular they're kind of
flat on the sides so what we can do is
take
maybe um let's
see let's go into like a side view or
something
just like this top view works let's go
to point mode i'm gonna hit zero i'm
gonna grab these edges here
and i'm gonna like scale them in towards
each other let's hit zero on these guys
let's scale these in towards each other
and we kind of have like a flat
rock look here i can rotate these a
little bit and it doesn't matter
too much if things are
asymmetrical that's totally fine because
it's a rock you know there's going to be
a lot of different variation to it so
i'm kind of just doing this low poly
version of this thing
and i could even grab this top piece
bring it up
a touch um i can grab these two pieces
bring them down a little bit
um maybe bring these down a touch
these guys here
and like this could maybe come up or
something just a little bit
yeah it just has some variation to it
and then we could even do one more cut
on the bottom
uh kl boom and then we could
scale in maybe this point here
um so scaling some of these side points
towards each other just a little bit to
get some variation in this thing
amazing all right so this is like our
base kind of thing here right
um let's go ahead and throw a
subdivision
modifier onto it so i'm going to hold
alt click this little button up here and
it's going to
throw a little subdivision surface onto
it and smooth
it out all right so from here
what i want to do is remember i
mentioned the
rock displacement texture along with the
rock normal i want to get the look
of this thing correct um
starting from i don't want it to glow
yet
i don't want it to glow yet i just want
to get the surface of this thing
looking correct without any color
or reflection or anything like that but
one thing i will do
before i jump into the displacement as a
placeholder
is use an hdri
hdri image here to light my scene just
to get me a little something
so i'm gonna make an octane sky and i'm
using
um grayscale gorilla for all this stuff
they're the
best absolutely the best hdri link plus
their new plus service is super solid
let's go ahead and drag that texture in
there and now we can open the plus
library and just like find
whatever we want you know creative
office sure if it looks blown out it's
because it is you need to go to
the image and change the color profile
from embedded default to linear
and that'll just normalize things a
little bit there
cool all right um if you have a camera
again i'm in octane i'm talking about
octane and i'm gonna i'm just kind of
like blowing by the modeling process of
this because really we want to get to
the texturing that's what
we're talking about um and if you're in
blender or maya 3ds max whatever
follow along with me try and make it
work i think it's i know it's doable
in your program so the the things
transition they
they all you know interwork together
they're all just kind of basic 3d
modeling stuff so let's go ahead and
save your scene let's call this
rock salt stream
v1 amazing alright sweet so you can see
it's a little blown out
so with an octane camera tag on my
camera
under camera imager make sure that's
checked and crank highlight compression
and it'll pull that down it'll save some
of those for you
all right we got 540 people
up in this stream thanks for joining me
all good to see you guys i got my mushu
mug
my lucky cricket
and i am excited to show you guys
this awesome pbr shader it's very
satisfying
and maybe it'll be like my andre librov
little um fireflies in the bottle
thing maybe i'll just always have a cg
rock salt lamp in the background we'll
see
where did i get the i got it from
disneyland um
my fiancee picked it up for me in
disneyland i love it very much
okay let's keep going so we want to get
the shape of this thing right
so that we can throw a texture onto it
oh down i was in downtown disney
correction there we go
alright so let's um
let's make an octane
material honestly doesn't matter which
one glossy or
diffused doesn't doesn't matter and
apply it to the rock
and i'm just gonna real quick use the
grayscale gorilla
plus library and grab a wood
texture
just to throw on to this like little
base piece
i'll just drag this in and slap it down
on this base piece here
let's change the let's go to cubic
and we can no this will be cylindrical
no it will not it's going to be cubic
and let's go ahead and just offset this
thing a little bit
and let's adjust the roughness
let's go into that node view unlink that
and just crank the roughness up
awesome that'll work for now okay
so let's go ahead into this rock
material
um
here we go in fact i actually have this
window docked up here so i can just kind
of hop
in let's go bam
and let's get it up in there and there
we go
we can you know i never really need to
see my model and the texture at the same
time
i just kind of see in my preview window
bonsai thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you thank you so much
um bonsai says been a huge fan since
carbo warfare 2.
that's a long time um you've inspired me
to delve into 3d and don't think i'd be
where i am without you good luck with
your movie
dude thank you i hope i hope you learned
something on this stream and yes i'm
very excited for my movie too
i'm working with a writer nate davis
right now and
uh we actually are going to be talking
on tuesday to figure out characters
and uh characters and
what else kind of like an outline we
have a general view of the movie
but i'm very excited to get into it it's
gonna be good yeah i'm making a movie
that's why i got in all this that's why
i'm doing 3d stuff
so i can do 3d for my own movies
what's up william good to see you man
welcome welcome
okay so i am using
um let's see vfx materials
i'm using rd textures like i told you
guys
so let me just navigate to that real
quick
party textures is probably the best
textures ever these things are
incredible
um and i want to find one that
looks and feels right for us
again if you guys want free stuff you
can go to texturehaven.com
or you can go to cc0texters.com
um and let's see
again this is just like a placeholder
thing okay this works actually
yeah this one totally works so let's go
to texture and i want
the
the 4k depth map as well as the
4k normal map and i'm going to drag
those out in here
um the first attempt thank you for
the super chat i appreciate it man say
you're actually testing out vegan
by finishing and rendering uh my attempt
at a challenge submission that i've
never got to finish
um i like it yeah dude it's legit
it's very good um you know obviously i
had to use it to piece together
the video and i used it to adjust those
uh i've used it for a while i guess
because
they sponsored a stream a while ago and
i really enjoy it
it's a very cool service if you guys
like don't have a computer
for 3d it's a good way to get into it
so i'm going to apply this normal map
and the displacement can't just be piped
into displacement
you actually have to have like a bridge
node
so this bridge is the gap the
displacement node here so i'm gonna pipe
that in
and it looks crazy because it's height
is set to 10 centimeters and remember we
set this to scale so
i think three centimeters will be good
for us the mid-level
is basically the grays um
stay at zero blacks go down and the
whites go up
and because we chose 4k we want to
choose the 4k texture
and you notice here that we're getting
these like seams
ripping on the top they're also
ripping a little bit on the bottom i
believe
so there's a couple ways to fix that um
let's set our diffuse to just like a
gray so it's a little easier to see
yeah and we probably don't need the
plane right now i'm going to delete that
i'm going to make a new
hdr environment and set it its type to
visible
so that's just your visible background
evan yo thanks for the super chat
just keep doing what you love love your
work man thank you so much
much appreciated and same to you brother
same to you as well
keep up all your passions keep working
at it
you know it's going to take us time to
get to the point where we want to be
but you're not going to get there if you
don't work at it
we've got to keep working at it all
right let's up the
amount here all right now the seam we
want to take care of this seam how are
we going to do that
a couple ways so in the displacement
node the type
set it to vertex displacement and that
takes care of the seam there
but you notice that it kind of got a
little low poly
that's because the vertex displacement
uses
the um the mesh data
to displace the polygons so the more
polygons you have
the um basically
the the higher and more detailed
the displacement will be so if we crank
this
up to say like four you can see it's
getting more detailed
and five is even more detailed so five
feels pretty good to me
but the way it's wrapped around this
thing is a little janky so let's see if
we can't fix that
i'll do that by changing the projection
up here i'm going to click the material
and let's go down to like
cylindrical i think is what i used for
the last one i did
and that looks janky um let's get rid of
this wireframe view
and let's go to this little like texture
mode up here
if you click this you can actually scale
it down
crunch it and kind of get more of a
natural
look out of this thing
it's got a little whoa that's serious
got a little butt
right there let's see if we can't um
offset it
so it doesn't have that really intense
piece there let's maybe like push it
down
or something and then
open this up a little bit and move it up
a little bit
and that is starting to look a little
bit
better and can probably get us
where we want to be
it's got a little butt all right let's
push this thing down
it's the whole rock itself so it's
sitting
maybe here maybe instead of the mid
level as 0.5
let's try the mid level as 0
and see if that doesn't look a little
bit better i think that looks a little
bit better it's not
as intense so i can push that down so
it's sitting on this pedestal
and the pedestal if we scale it
down a little bit it's like the rock is
kind of taking over the pedestal which i
like because that's how mine look
um let's go ahead and do this by the way
guys
um if if you guys
the the only the only way i'm able to do
this accurately is because i have
reference i'm maybe
i'm able to look at these two salt rocks
to my left and right
and actually use those things as
reference and scrutinize and ask all the
questions like
how does this look and how can i
translate it to this i'm giving you guys
like the answer
basically um to the question
of how do i do this but it took the way
i did it myself was just by
looking at these rocks having an
understanding of how textures work which
i'm hopefully going to be able to
um you know communicate to you guys on
the stream here
so that you guys can do this yourself we
got another super chat don't we
joseph thank you dude thanks for the
super chat he says i'm having a blast
following your live streams and excited
for your career after corridor keep up
the awesome work and thanks for
inspiring also what is the two finger
glove that you wear
that's a good question this thing is i
guess it's called a
hand or pants because it looks like
pants but it's also on my hand
it's a weird name um it's so i don't get
like
all the oils from my hand over my wacom
tablet
when i'm using it so i use a pen tablet
uh wacom
fantastic company these guys are amazing
and it just helps me glide across the
surface of my tablet
way smoother and it kind of it
it elongates the duration and the life
span of the tablet just
a little bit more so it's nice i like it
a lot
let's get back to it
um what gpu am i using i'm using a
quadro rtx
6000 it's got that 24 gigabytes of vram
and honestly would not be able to do my
like
large projects without it i'm a big fan
um yeah yeah enough said
all right let's hold on one second
all right we back
okay so let's um we have a pretty good
like placeholder for this
rock here we can adjust this later
but let's uh let's dive into the actual
like
rock texture and start lighting this
thing up
it's gonna be fun fun fun all right so
let's save
um i'm gonna save an iteration so ctrl
shift
s to save as and i'll just do a v2
and let's let's start this so
hmm
we're gonna have to switch our
displacement map here
to a let's see
let's switch it to a specular so right
now
this is just glass and if i were to make
a light
and i set the octane light i go to its
details
the area shape you can set to sphere and
i'm gonna hit t
and scale it way down and there's
basically a little light
inside of this glass rock thing
that is illuminating the rock from the
inside
but it obviously doesn't look like where
we want to be
so how do we get it there that's why you
guys are here that's why you clicked on
the video
so here's what we have to do this is
like the sauce on it this is the secret
sauce
and this is what takes us like halfway
there
it's the medium you see this medium
right here
if i were to go to medium and
let's do an absorption and a scattering
all right what it's what it's doing is
basically adding like a like a fog
pass inside of this if i set the density
to zero
it would just be as if you know we
didn't add anything so
i can go to compare store render buffer
and let's take the density to 100 and
you can see that
it's adding this little like fog it's
filling it
with stuff basically and it's thickening
it up
but if i were to take that to like 50
you can see that
you know it's on the outsides it's not
as thick
but on the center it's it's thicker it's
certainly
thicker in the center you can see the
light it doesn't quite reach it all the
way through the middle but on the edges
it's passing through because it has a
it's a little bit a little bit thinner
you know what i mean
so with that
um we're able to kind of build out
this orange pinkish uh
peach kind of kind of feel
that fogs up the inside of this rock
because if you're to look at the
reference here
if i turn on the light on this thing
obviously you guys can't see it but
you can see into the rock which is why
i'm using
a specular material or a glass material
you know
so if you guys are at this point if
you've made it this far give me a thumbs
up
if you're still with me or if you're
just enjoying the video give me a little
smiley face
all right so let's leave this
this render storing the render let's go
ahead and store this buffer
so we have a new one now all right yeah
y'all are just enjoying the video we got
some people some thumbs ups hanging out
all right very cool
thank you guys for joining this thing
thank you guys for supporting the
channel it means a lot
um most of you guys know that i did
leave
um corridor digital in order to pursue
my youtube channel and my creative
passions
full time so it means a lot that you
guys are here thank you so much
um it's gonna be fun it's gonna be a
good year i'm very excited
but don't worry me and the corridor guys
are cool we we got lunch yesterday
um we had some beers and some bratwursts
it was a good time
all right
so absorption and scattering that's what
we need to mess with all right let's
take our density back up to 100
and you'll notice that like based off
of what's the easiest way to show this i
can probably pull up
yeah let me let me show you guys so this
is where i got yesterday and i was like
this looks like butt this looks so
bad but then i got to this point here
which it looks so much better it looks
so much better
um this is obviously light on light off
um so hopefully we can bypass
this look and just get straight to this
because this looks so good i'm really
proud of how that turned out
and i think i have a video too i can
play for you guys
yeah so this is like it's spinning
around
and uh is it looping it's looping yeah
yeah spinning around and like lighting
up and stuff
feels really cool
all right so what was i gonna say
yes you see how it's like the inside of
this thing
let me see if i can just like make this
a little easier for you guys to see here
um
there we go yeah so the inside of this
it's it's rough
meaning the light is diffused
um so that you cannot see the source of
the light
whereas in our current setup you can see
the source of the light
does that make sense to you guys so
that's going to be
fixed with the the roughness let me just
give it some roughness
so let's go to roughness here and just
crank it
and you can see how it distributes that
that light and diffuses that light
around this whole thing so that's a big
big big difference between what we had
without the roughness
and and with the roughness all right
so let's go ahead and save another
render pass um
so that we can keep doing some fun
iterations here let's let's focus on the
color
because the color took me a while to get
all right so let's
let's throw a rgb spectrum into the
absorption
so this is kind of confusing for me
but you're only gonna get there when you
experiment
so let's change the color on this thing
what if this was like a peach
pinky peach color
it's going to kind of scatter
that color around or absorb that color i
don't know if there's scattering and
absorption
i'm still getting the hang of it um
right now it looks like a like a
jellyfish or something
um let's see if i can't
what if i were to change the the
brightness
so the brightness definitely turns it
down if i go full brightness on it
that gets intense all right that gets
really intense let me also change the
color of my light
let's do like a 3200 so it's more of a
warmer
situation okay
all right so that's way too intense
but let's see if we can just take down
that brightness just a little bit
and maybe go like for a little yellowish
just to touch yellow
and let's add some scattering to it as
well so
what happens if we go with like a
reddish pinkish kind of
color here something bright and
saturated
okay that kind of looks washed out
you know we're kind of there let's let's
take the light and
really give it some light so i'm
cranking that to 300
and that's not bad honestly that's that
is not too shabby right here
um it's cool because
this like pinkish color up here is not
being affected
by this light but it is at the same time
because
basically what's happening is anything
in this like center point the hot point
of the light is getting
this you know this color your absorption
color and then as it falls off
and it's still illuminated um it's
getting
the scattering color so let's let's see
if we can't lock in these colors a
little bit better
william thank you for the super chat
it's good to see you man
um you say could you give us some info
on
the upcoming movie of yours um
great work by the way the pipelord
the prodigy william's stuff is
incredible
um yeah you do really solid stuff man
the upcoming movie so yeah
i mean i got into all of this stuff to
direct a movie i
if you look at my older work on my
channel you'll see all my short films
all my
you know action movie stuff my comedy
stuff
uh my vfx based stuff and
you know i i basically
you know have been doing this for more
than 10 years
man i've been i've been in california
back in california for 10 years
but i've been doing shorts for probably
16 years at this point
and there's just so many ideas i have
and i i want to do something longer form
because for me it's very satisfying to
tell the story
over a longer period of time than just
five or six minutes on youtube
so i i don't know how much i should give
out right now i should probably talk
with my uh
writing partner nate and figure out like
what can be said but
you know i'll give you guys this much i
want to make a movie that has heart
that has drama that has comedy
action mystery you know i want like the
whole shebang
and i want to be able to tell a really
fun exciting
mysterious beautiful story with heart
and that's character focused and
story focused and i just want to do my
best to make it look as good
as possible and hit as hard as possible
and i want to work with
the best stunt men and women that i can
get on this thing i want to work with
the best actors i want to get some
name actors that you guys probably know
um and we want to do it legit
so it's going to be awesome and it's
going to be adventurous
that's another thing it's going to be
adventurous and it's going to be fun
but it's also going to be a little scary
too you know a little
scary so i'll leave it at that
let's get back to it william thanks i
appreciate it man
um and derek thank you sir for the super
chat
no words necessary dude uh i just
appreciate
you okay so we have our color here
let me let me just go back to my
previous salt lamp model
and let's see
how this is set up
so my absorption and scattering these
are my colors here maybe i can copy
these guys
let's see if i can't copy all just these
just the colors i just want to get the
colors right because they really were
dialed in
and i think i cranked the density let's
go back
into this guy i'm cheating a little bit
all right i'll paste them in boom so we
got our colors let's see what's the
difference
so this one's just brighter okay so
let's let's just make it brighter
oh yeah that really that really gets it
looking nice
and then my scattering is just
a little little de-saturated a little
more on the red side
um so we'll desaturate it a little bit
we'll get it more to the red side
and we'll see what that does for us and
i think i just need to
bring down the brightness of it
and then yeah we really start to get
this look here
awesome
and it's still a little too saturated
let me just pipe this one in
and that's yeah that like really
saturates it up so it looks to me like
let's see let's pipe this one in too
a little bit more saturation on that
just a touch not too much though
yeah it seems to me like the darker you
go
on the scattering the more saturated
that gets
so we don't want to go that intense i
really dialed these in here
um and then i think i had this
density up a little bit more yeah so it
makes it a little thicker
we can take our light and make it
brighter just really crank that light
it feels good to me and we can make the
light a little bigger as well so we can
just scale it up a little bit so it's
getting a little bit more area on it
and let's move it down move it down a
little bit
and make sure it's centered up yeah
we're good
and if for whatever reason that your
your viewport's like this you can hit n
c and that'll you know change your
viewport to the point where there's no
lights
look at that difference so this is this
is us just messing with the color there
so the color is a big difference in this
um now the next main thing that
that makes up this rock salt lamp
is the like crystal residue
that you guys can see here let me pull
this up for you guys
so there's like a crystal residue on
this thing
right um it's on the top it's kind of on
the edges of everything
kind of towards the bottom but it's not
across the entire thing it's just on the
edges really
so i've noticed so what i'm doing for
that is actually using a dirt node
and real quick let's just turn off the
light to see what it looks like without
and that feels pretty good to me yeah
you can see how the light passes through
it let's rotate our hdri a little bit
you can see how it fills up it's like a
nice subsurface scattering look it
really fills that up
and with the light on like that's
looking really cool i'm digging this a
lot
we can rotate our rock salt lamp to find
like a better angle on this thing
and the base feels a little a little
chunky to me so i'm just gonna
adjust that a little bit
awesome daniel thank you
yeah the stuntman react episodes are
really fun i enjoy him a lot
um and yeah even though i've left
corridor you know i'm still going to be
there for some of those videos
so don't you guys worry it's a good time
let's save an iteration so we can uh
look at look at all of our work and see
how far we've come so this is looking
really cool
i'm digging this let's let's save um a
render buffer
so we can just keep taking track of our
work here
alright so let's uh
let's do this like crystal layer that
makes up the
diffuse channel so as you can see in our
specular
material there is no diffuse channel
right there's just roughness and
reflection
so we might actually have to switch to a
universal material
to get this look but for the time
being right so that's just our roughness
for the time being let's um
let's change this to a diffuse
texture
cool and let me take
out um let's take out this
this here let's turn off the light
and let's go to
let's refresh the render
i don't know why it's looking like this
it shouldn't be looking like this
um is it because our diffuse isn't
turned up
let's see i'm just going to go down the
list here and see why it's acting this
way it shouldn't be transmission
the medium is taken off
um maybe this is just like an octane
thing
is being janky on us
diffuser changes to glossy
for whatever reason that fixes things
um cool all right
so i'm gonna use a dirt node the dirt
node
is fantastic because it allows you to
just kind of hit the edges of your model
it makes a nice little mask for us
let's open this up and let's zoom in
okay
and let's adjust these settings so right
now we don't really see anything
um and the reason i'm piping it into the
diffuse channel is just so i can see it
i want to be able to work
with these different steps that we're
taking
in their most basic form so i just make
it simple on me
make it quick pipe it into into the
diffuse channel without any lights and
fancy stuff going on just make it easy
on yourself
kind of whittle down the problem you
guys ever have your computer
crash on you and it just keeps crashing
on you and you have to like
you know really dilute the issue what's
the issue you unplug your keyboard you
unplug your tablet you unplug your
monitors until you get it down to just
the power cord on your computer does
that work
if that doesn't work then it's something
inside your computer you got to keep
going further
so that's what i'm doing i'm just
isolating the parts that i'm working on
the strength all right let's take the
strength to 10 always
that's just so i can see what's going on
the radius we can take to 2 centimeters
let's take the radius to 10 centimeters
and it doesn't really look like it's
doing anything
um so let me zoom out just a touch
and let me invert the normal and
maybe crank the details a little bit i
mean it's doing something
we can see it doing a little something i
basically want this on the edges that's
what the dirt map does the dirt map says
like
let's see
yeah the dirt map will hit um either the
edges or the corners of your stuff
so let's make this uh displacement
really obvious let's set the height to
like
10. you can see here that it's hitting
the edges all the points that are like
sticking out from this thing if we
checked or unchecked invert normal it's
just going to get the crevices
or is that the other way around it's
kind of a little hard to tell to be
honest
but yeah i think that's the crevices
and that is the edges so we want
the edges we want to affect the edges
let's take the displacement back down to
the size that we liked it
maybe we can go four centimeters
maybe even maybe what we do is let's
take this uh
texture on here and scale it up a little
bit so it's going to tile
less than once it'll tile 0.8
yeah maybe something like that
cool so we're we're just making a mask
for ourselves um this mask is gonna help
um basically
this will be this dirt node let me see
if i can explain this
this dirt node is going to differentiate
between
the himalayan salt rock that we just
made
and the crystal layer on top
right so the black areas will be the
crystal layer that we're seeing
and the white areas will just be the
lamp from the inside
and i want to crank this a little bit
more let's bring the spread
up what is it maybe it's the
distribution up
yeah so it's like really getting in
there and really like starting to spread
around
that feels good to me
awesome so that
feels pretty good let's like rotate
around this
yeah that's where all like the the
crystal areas are gonna be
it feels pretty good
awesome
so from here
let's see if we can just change this
back
to a universal no no let's go yeah it's
going to have to be a universal material
because this gives us all the options as
opposed to glossy or diffuse which gives
us some of the options this gives us
everything
it comes kind of metallicy by default
so i'm going to take the metallic down
to zero and then we're kind of looking
at what we were looking at before
let's pipe the emission or the medium
back in
and that doesn't look normal it's the
albedo that needs to
come down it needs to be zero albedo
um which is basically color
what is happening here why is this
problem solving that is a huge part
of what you do as a vfx artist is
problem solving all day all night
all right so the light turns on it just
looks a little hazy i think it's because
of the albedo
and if we change it to black
so it looks like black
hmm interesting black and white
pipe this in
so what that's doing is kind of the
opposite of what we want it is
it is showing the
the lamp
it's the crevices here that are being uh
that have the crystal layer we want it
the opposite
so for whatever reason this is acting
like an alpha so if i take that off
or if i take this to black
interesting
jones lab what's up man hey thank you
for the super chat he says
uv unwrap and paint some spaceships soon
maybe
maybe we'll do some spaceships at some
point
it'd be uh that'd be like a multi-stream
endeavor though
sounds like fun i appreciate the super
chat man thank you
okay let's maybe try um
let's throw an invert on this thing
we're in problem solving mode at this
point let's throw an invert on it and
see what happens okay
that's intense um
uh let's see what is this is white
i don't know if the invert is helping us
if i uncheck that
okay that is going on the edges now
that is on the edges it's very
it's very intense i want it to kind of
fade off so maybe the details need to
come back a little bit
and it's a lot of it happening so maybe
we take the radius to one
that's kind of in the inverse of what we
want so maybe the radius is 3
5 10.
we're just hitting the edges here maybe
the radius goes to
20. i don't know why it's
like it shouldn't have to be this insane
that's just the way it's looking now
this is just a white and i don't like
that
so we need to maybe bring this dirt map
down to zero okay that does that
but what if i give it an octane gradient
the octane gradient will allow us to
take the whites
and turn the grays and the blacks to
dark grays
so if i were to bring this down to a
black it would be as if
it wasn't on in the first place okay so
here's what i'm going to do
we're back to our original setup
let's go ahead and save this render
right here and let's kind of walk this
up a little
bit so that we get this crystally
look over the top of this stuff
all right that's not bad we're getting
there
it's very subtle if we go full white
it's just going to be way too much
looks like snow i'm going to bring it to
like this point here
but i kind of wanted to ramp up into to
a brighter
a brighter look
so let's see if we can't um
hmm how would i do this
how would i do this maybe i need to
clamp it so i crunch it down
really intensely
oh okay that kind of
crunches a little bit maybe i change
this one to white
so it gets a little bit brighter
but i only want the areas that are like
really bright to be that bright so
i'm gonna crunch it down like this
that's crazy how it's that that's
affecting it's so much
well let's um let's take a look and see
what i did in my other one here
it's nice to have spent hours and hours
and hours on this
um yesterday because i got my little
answer right here
so this is what we're doing this is it
right here it's just the grade they're
just the dirt node and the gradient
that's
it i'm gonna copy all this
in fact let's just copy this over i
don't want to cheat too hard
we'll get there
let's paste it in
and see the difference here so
very intense difference um
the gradient let's just pipe this in and
see what it does
and refresh it
okay let's up the subdivision count so
it's even
more
high poly whoa
looks like an alien brain
that's just an error i know that for
sure
okay interesting
interesting i kind of like
what we had before here i like this look
i can maybe make this a little bit
brighter
now what i want to do is i think it's
like dispersed
yep audio vision is right on it it's
um it's dispersed a little too much
there's too much of this white
uh crystal layer on top so
i'm going to use a noise map to kind of
break it up
but first shout outs to the first
attempt with another super chat thank
you
um sweet awesome i'm glad vegan's
working says well i let vegan do its
rendering thing i'm about to
grab a rocketeer figurine and see about
potential
part-time dev position awesome congrats
congratulations very cool thank you for
the super chat i appreciate it
okay let's see
let's grab that noise node octane noise
we'll grab
grab it out here and let's just pipe it
in to the albedo
to see what it's doing i'm gonna just
crank the contrast
to a hundred i always do this so i can
see what it's doing
and this is great yeah i wanna break
this up
so but i don't want it to be in these
larger chunks let's go ahead and just
take the omega to 0.9
which is gonna kind of break that up a
little bit more and we can take the
octaves to eight
and we'll work the gamma back so it's
just kind of revealing
or it's just pulling away certain parts
like so so what we'll do is we'll
multiply these together
to essentially take away
some of this
texture here let's pipe this other one
in i like that a little bit better
cool
all right
so let's go ahead and grab a multiply
node
and we'll pipe multiply node into the
albedo we'll get that the texture too
and hopefully if we pipe this in it's
only going to
show that crystal on certain areas of
this thing so if we
take the gamma down it'll be the full
the full deal basically but if we take
the gamma up it'll start chipping away
at which parts are seen let me try
inverting this
and i'm slowly just wait walking the
gamma
back to reveal
that layer um and then let's take this
so it's a little bit brighter
we can get rid of these guys
and for the projection on the and the
noise is fine
it's okay we can leave it as is
let's just work that gamma
that feels pretty good to me
that's pretty cool so let's mess with
the
roughness try to take it down to zero
obviously it would look like glass
which we don't want
and it's at a pretty nice spot here
if we were to max it out you know it'd
be
something like that but i like around
point three or so
because it's still reflective it's still
catching light
what i want to do here is actually
let's see
let's give it some like little
reflective pieces
because it does catch the light in a
very specific way
and certain parts are super reflective
while other parts are a bit more rough
so here's what i'll do
let's make a let's just actually copy
we'll control drag this noise
and we'll pipe it into the albedo again
just to see what it's doing okay
actually let's uh right click solo it
and yeah we can see it there so what
i'll do here
is i want to kind of work this down so
we're just getting let's switch this
so we're just getting these white little
pieces that
that like poke through um let's take the
omega to 0.8 and you can see when you
bring the omega down
it just kind of like changes the
resolution of it a bit more
and i will adjust the scale so
projection let's pipe that out to
projection node we'll change it to xyz
to uvw
um and we'll just kind of scale this
texture down
yeah so there's going to be little
points where it's really reflective
and other points where it looks normal
basically
all right so we'll pipe this
into the roughness
let's see what it does
and we need to pipe in our albedo
now right now it's doing the opposite of
what we want this roughness it's
actually shining through
um and making those little tiny areas
that are white
those are the rough parts but we want
the dark gray to be the rough parts
so what if we were to just invert this
let me see i'll just click
invert and it's not really doing what we
want it to do
so what i'll do in that case is i'll
grab an octane gradient
drop it on here and just flip these
uh these parameters so now we get to
that that rough
look but certain parts here are actually
like shining through
um and really you know kind of
it's not spreading the reflection out
it's focusing it so it's like a mirror
almost
but that's looking pretty sweet let's
rotate around this and see what it looks
like
and i can see a little bit of fireflies
in here so i'm going to
subtly in my octane camera tag under
camera imager i'm just going to
bring down that hot pixel removal a
little bit
just a little bit not too much
awesome awesome
so yeah the the wrapping is
certainly not ideal up here
nor is it ideal here on the side
i think that's just the way it is um
if i offset this a little bit
that's really intense
let me adjust the roughness
here let's take the black what if we go
full white with the black
alright that takes away our little
highlights but what if we go full
black with the white okay that brings
everything back in so i just kind of
want to
crank this up a little bit so it's not
super intense
and we can bring this down a bit too so
it's not
it's not as reflective
another thing you can do here is do a
coating layer
so under coating coating layer
you can give it a little bit basically
crank that up and over top
everything it gives it like a layer of
like slime
or gloss or something and there is kind
of this like coating over top of
everything on this lamp
so i can crank that a little bit and
give it a little roughness
to kind of break it up just a little bit
that's a really cool
a really cool thing that you can do with
universal materials and octane
um artem yo thank you for the super chat
i appreciate you man
you say uh are you gonna review
challenge entries at the end of the
stream
absolutely i always do and i love the
strict deadline to finish the image
in one week only yeah man me too i think
it's a cool way for you guys to really
dive into the work and you know get your
hands dirty
and and just get better you know at 3d
every single week that's the thing you
got to keep it consistent so
uh shout outs to all you guys who have
consistently done these 3d challenges i
hope you guys have been learning a lot
while doing so
okay
let me try something crazy what if i
pipe the dirt node
into metallic that looks crazy
what if i pipe the dirt node
into
transmission that looks like lava that's
really cool
you get some really cool looks out of
this
that's awesome and we can switch out
these textures too
for
the 8k versions so i might even just do
that i'm gonna
locate it and i'll switch these out so
depth is 8k
and normal is also 8k
just to get the highest resolution on
these things
now i'm about at the point here
where this is pretty matched up to
what i was doing here i think the only
difference is the
uh the rock displacement that i'm using
and i actually prefer this one in this
thumbnail so let me see if i can't
find it let's go window rock salt
and fine what is this this is eight
number eight and we're using what are we
using
thirteen all right let's locate eight
i'm i'm feeling eight that's a good one
texture uh depth
let's pipe that in and
same for the normal we'll pipe that in
these are rd
textures real displacement textures is
what they're called
and that gives us a nice a nice look
there
let's see if we can't bring the
displacement down maybe to like three or
something
that feels a little bit better um red
beast vfx
my goodness thank you for the super chat
very very kind of you
you say that your streams and tutorials
for the robot has been a big help for
learning c4d is there a chance that you
may do some beginner tutorial lessons in
a similar vein
of blender guru's donut tutorial um
yeah absolutely always a chance man so i
want to do like an intro to c4d um maybe
like how to set up your own custom ui
and some like two minute five minute
tutorials
i've been thinking about it yeah i've
certainly have been thinking about it
so i got a lot of plans for the channel
a lot of videos i want to do
um and that's one of them so absolutely
i'm glad you've learned something from
all these streams and
that you're continuing to do so thank
you for the super chat i appreciate you
man
um it's really awesome
all right
yeah and you can mess with the shape of
this thing any way you want to
let's go ahead and store the render
buffer
and maybe we just need to scale this
whole thing down
and maybe it needs to like taper to a
point a bit more so i'm hitting q
um to take off the
yeah so maybe it's more of a or
something like that
and we can make little cuts in here
and just change the shape of this thing
a little bit
and we can kind of bring this
down to change the shape
now for whatever reason the dirt note is
only working on the one side
and i i don't know why maybe that's just
because
the lighting yeah i guess it is the
lighting
but you're still able to see that stuff
even though you don't have the lighting
here so let me let me turn off this
light
and just look at this without
it's a little intense there's too much
of it
so i think what we need to do is work
our dirt node settings
and the radius maybe can just come down
to one
the distribution maybe it's the spread
yeah it looks like it's the spread
and what if we just take this to like
tolerance do we crank that
it's weird it's doing the kind of like
the opposite of what i wanted to do
maybe the spread
now spread makes too much of it
what if we change the bias i don't know
what that does i really don't
um
we bring the strength back that that's
crazy
oh snap hans my goodness thank you
thank you thank you for that super chat
you said you've been an inspiration
since i was 14 that's six years ago
your determination motivation and
aspiration is something out of this
world learning from you feels nothing
short of a privilege
cgi has changed my life and i have you
to thank for it my goodness man that is
quite the compliment i don't know how to
take that that is awesome
um yeah man i'm i'm
you know it's it's my pleasure really i
enjoy doing this
the way i see it is like i'm i'm gonna
be learning for the rest of my life
in all aspects of life so
you know why not help out a little bit
and share with you guys
my process and how i do some of it at
least when it comes to
you know cgi and filmmaking and all that
stuff so
you know i'm really glad that i'm able
to help and
you know inspire you to do the stuff
that you love doing
so i'll always be here uh creating cool
stuff
so hang out anytime man i appreciate you
thank you for that super chat it's very
very generous of you
and christian i see you too man it's
been a minute
yeah things are going well things are
going very well there's it's very busy
you know leaving corridor and um doing
my thing has been
it's been busy it's been very very busy
but i
am very happy with my decision and i
can't wait to knock stuff out i'm
trying to get this render challenge
going for you guys parallel dimensions
too
i mean if i call it parallel dimensions
again i guess it would still be fitting
but i'm in the process of locking a
bunch of really cool prizes
and i have four out of five locked
you guys are gonna be blown away at
these prizes
and it's all international too all right
um i want to make it all international
for you guys
i want everyone have a chance to win
this stuff so it's going to be very
exciting
very very exciting yeah that'll be in
the next few weeks we'll be announcing
it this
month alright so you know keep watching
the videos
subscribe if you guys aren't subscribed
and you guys will know about this new
render challenge coming out very soon if
you don't know what i'm talking about
just go to my channel the video that
auto plays the
125 artists create from a prompt like
that's what i'm talking about we're
gonna do another one
and it's gonna be really good very
excited
but let's uh let's hop back in
i appreciate you guys so
let's copy over the dirt node
and the gradient from this
other one here i'm just going to copy
everything and paste it in
and we're doing the same thing i'm just
the settings are just tweaked a little
bit more
all right so let's paste it in
and if you hold shift it'll take the
entire hierarchy with it
so you can see the same thing as a dirt
node with a gradient in through multiply
is multiply with a noise map
and that noise that noise node is just
hooked up with
basically a projection node and
transform node just like we did with
this one on roughness
so what if we just pipe this in what
would it look like
yeah i think it looks a little bit
better it's a little bit more subdued
i think that's just because
my spread is down to my radius and my
spread
are lowered in this one which totally
works
so i'll take it
all right let's store this render and
i'm really happy with the color
i'm very happy with the color of this
thing
let's see
that looks like a salmon slab that's
pretty cool
and that's just a glitch you got to turn
on and off your subdivision surface
there
come on octane keep up
what's going on
let's turn on our light see what things
look like
hmm octane's getting chunky
that's not good we may have to restart
what's up ricardo thank you man south
africa very cool
maybe one day i'll make it out there i
love traveling
hans my goodness man you are tearing it
up today
very nice okay you say if you don't mind
me asking which tablet are you using
how is it how has it improved your
workflow and are there any cons that you
can think of
have an awesome weekend dude you're the
best
yeah this thing's great it is a uh
a i think it's pronounced wacom
w-a-c-o-m
they're like the biggest in the industry
this is an intuos
pro paper version
um number four it's the fourth one um
the paper
is fine you know you can put paper on
top of it and draw on the paper and
it'll draw in photoshop just like you're
actually sketching on paper if you're
used to sketching on paper
i don't use it but um just the intuos
pro 4 or i think they have a 5 at this
point
is amazing this company is great
and if you guys
stick around for the render challenge
you
maybe um you know there's some cool
prizes that's all i'm gonna say right
now there's some cool prizes guys
yeah i love this thing it's great the
pen is awesome
and it's a good time thank you for that
second super chat that's very
very generous of you dude that's great
how has it improved my workflow the
reason i have this thing
is because it uh
it basically saves my wrist i got it for
health reasons i didn't want to have
carpal tunnel with the mouse for the
rest of my life
so i know i know that i'm going to be
doing cg for the rest of my life
um at least it'll be an aspect of my
creative career
so i wanted to be able to go for
longevity and use the tablet because
it's healthier on your hand um
i just got really used to it it's a
essential part of my workflow i love it
that's the best so yeah the wacom intuos
pro
4. i think they got a 5 out
i'm gonna restart cinema
and just because you know octane's being
all janky
i'm happy to answer any of you guys any
of your guys's questions over the next
minute here while this
reboots
what tablet would i recommend for
photoshop editing i mean this one's
great
i really love it yeah it's the medium
size i don't like the
huge size but that's just personal
preference you know you guys might
might enjoy that
let's bam open that up
all right will i ever try out blender
maybe maybe maybe i get that question so
often
but i always say it's like using my
right hand
versus my left hand i'm using my right
hand right now on c4d
but i don't know i could spend a lot of
time learning how to use my left hand
but
i use my right hand that's just how it
is for me at least
um what school did i go to i
went to uh let's see
i went to chino hills high school
for ninth grade but moved to atlanta
and went to a school called the
creekview high school
and i was actually the first graduating
class
ever in that in that school so it was
pretty pretty awesome
they just built it brand new school and
from there
um you know my dad really wanted me to
go to college and get a degree but i
really wanted to come out to la and work
with freddie
but so you know we figured it out i came
out and ended up
working with freddie i dropped out but i
was going to a tech school called
chattahoochee technical college they
have a few locations
it's just a two-year technical school
and i got about a year and a half
through they taught photoshop after
effects illustrator
i think a little bit of cinema 4d but i
was
already like i already knew all those
programs at the time
because you know i was doing andrew
kramer video co-pilot and i was doing
like
cg tuts.com and stuff
um because it's my passion i was doing
it my free time
okay let's switch back
alright we're good it's working now
very cool let's take this down a little
bit i think it's a little heavy
um and let's let's drop this guy up in
here
whoa that's looking crazy why does
octane have to do this on me every time
it's just like
jankiness
refresh
all right um yeah let's just take this
down a little bit
so the gradient um in the dirt map if i
take this
change it to a black yeah that just kind
of
softens that up a little bit it's
looking nice looking very
very nice
cool all right um this is pretty close i
think the last thing i want to do here
is is just add like
some detail on the inside when the light
is turned on i want to be able to see
stuff that you can't see
when the light is off um but my goodness
oscar and canisi
thank you guys so much for that super
chat that is very very kind of you guys
so oscar says thanks for everything
you've done been following you since you
started corridor you inspired me to be
better
and see you as one of my role models man
that is awesome that is really
weird for me to read out loud but that
is awesome thank you so much
that is super cool man welcome to the
stream i hope you're learning something
and canisi
the super chat much appreciated man um
you say that you've never seen this kind
of lamp in real life
but somehow i know that you're nailing
it dude that's great thank you man
if i could pull one of these from my
desk and rip it off
the wall and hold it right here i'd show
you but it's connected to the
to the wall you know because this one
it's it's a lamp you know
um and jones lab thank you for the super
chat
you say also using a wacom for 10 plus
years yup makes you a better artist
because the mouse can't do some things
well no pressure slash tilt yep um
there's no pressure or tilt on
the the mouse but you can really like
you know add pressure and make your pen
strokes
thicker you can add tilt to make them a
little bit more
have an angle to it when you're
photoshopped and you can roto
and mask stuff much faster it's great
like it really is the best
my goodness hans jeez dude thank you wow
i think that's like
the most generous super chat i've ever
had on
this stream ever thank you
man that is amazing
thank you so much dude wow
you guys are the best thank you so much
all right all right all right
rock on y'all thank you for your support
i appreciate y'all yeah freaking crazy
yeah that's that's insane
um hans is popping off today
man so cool
okay let's see if we can't get that that
like detail
in the center of this thing so i'm just
gonna render region
and how how the heck am i going to do
this
here's an idea here's a crazy idea
what if i duplicate this material
scale it down
and i give it a new material
so it's going to be
let's solo it let's solo the material
turn that off and i want this to
actually have
um i'm gonna make a whole new material
it'll be a diffused material let's apply
that diffuse material to that
new rock that we just scaled down
and let's
um let's actually duplicate the material
we have
and i'm gonna tweak
we'll it this new material to the scaled
down rock on the inside
and we'll refresh
all right now what i want to do here
is i i can lose
i can lose the albedo i don't need it i
basically want to make like a little
star field on the inside
i can lose the roughness i don't
need it i can even lose the normal map i
don't need it and i can lose
the scattering i don't need it i just
need this base
kind of layer of displacement on top
here
so that the star field on the inside
kind of you know
is it is at different levels on this
thing so let me see if i can't like uh
i don't want to do this would it be
under opacity
let's just bring out a noise node
octane noise in opacity let's set this
the contrast to 100
and let's take the omega point
let's just take it to one
okay so it's doing a little something
here let's take
the gamma all the way yeah here we go so
now it's kind of like lighting up just
tiny little pieces here
see it's like a little star field that
it's lighting up
on the inside now maybe that's
too intense maybe it's 0.9 and the
octaves go to like eight or something
and then we walk this back
and
i set it to like chips or something
and i want to take these and make them
i want to make them red
but it's still we're still not there
we're still not there i need to like
give it uh i need to crunch this down
even more
um i think it's the scale let me give it
projection and i'm gonna give it
transform let's take the projection to
xyz to uvw
so it wraps normally and let's scale it
way up to like 10
and i want to crunch this down with a
gradient so it's just black and white
there's not really any gray
i'll crank the black yeah you see that
so it's just like these little pieces
then from there we'll take the gamma and
we'll work it so that
yeah okay and then we'll take the
transform down to five
so we're getting a little something like
that okay
um i need to
probably scale this down further so
two perhaps
um take the omega to one again
that's starting to feel pretty good
let's uh
take the omega or the gamma down even
more so i want
less things showing up
0.8
and maybe we scale it down one more
yeah so we're getting some stuff on the
inside like that
okay so the albedo let's change the
color to a red
like a a really intense red
kind of dark brown maybe
a deep brown
and let's turn on our
original lamp and see if we can't see
that stuff
through it
we'll render a region and i don't really
see it um
oh my god dude what the heck
mr hans hauser bosh again
wow dude you are ridiculous you said
you were using the wrong youtube channel
whoops
cheers from nova scotia dude wow thank
you so much
thank you thank you thank you that is
insane
jeez man yeah definitely you have the
record here for
uh the most super chats by far
that is incredible and uh nova scotia i
feel like i've been i don't know exactly
where i've been to calgary and i've been
to
toronto but uh
i maybe nova scotia is i know there's
like chunks
of canada so maybe that's in there
somewhere
cool place very cool place my goodness
dude
that is insane thank you so much i
really appreciate you
um me and my fiance will get a nice
dinner on you man i
i really appreciate it thank you so much
that is awesome
mr hans g yes he is indeed
um all right that's freaking sweet
okay i can buy a bunch of salt rock
lamps now
that's sick all right so um
let's see here i'm not seeing it i'm not
seeing it on the inside
and that coating layer i'm not a fan of
so let's take that coating layer off
because it's not really doing what i
want it to do but it's not the coating
layer weird
dude he says get a haircut too my god
dude you're
ridiculous thank you so much
this isn't good enough for you if i just
like
just come back like this i used to have
the little hair clip i'm almost at hair
clip status now
it's been a minute but yes i do need a
haircut
i do need a proper chair too i'm on a
living room chair
but don't worry y'all cut it out too
much too much
thank you so much man that's incredible
yeah we're sitting down the standing
streams are rough on me those are
intense
all right let's let's do this let's get
this thing popping off
um
i don't know what happened to my
roughness
i guess it's hitting like it's this
light gray
it's this little corner piece up here
cool cool
um yeah i'm not seeing these guys on the
inside so maybe i need to scale it up a
little bit more
so it's like right up in there okay so
it's causing this weird
look here um
it doesn't need to be a universal
material i think it just needs to be a
diffuse
that i can is it why is it doing that
hmm
maybe because
maybe because
i wonder if i give
it like a surface imperfection
oh dude kevin you were there for that
the time i did
10 or 20 jump squats every time i got a
super chat
that was the worst i will i will never
do that ever again
i i like straight up injured my knee the
next day from that
i that was so dumb i don't i
forget which one it was uh
but it's in the vault somewhere
all right problem solving how do i get
why is this looking
it's making it look all glossy and weird
um i just need this little piece
if i can get this right maybe i just
need to scale it down more
um noeller thank you for the super chat
you say what made me decide to make this
i really like the randomization that can
be done cheers from buffalo so i have
two of them next to me and i love
looking at them they're beautiful
um the light from the inside it looks
like there's a galaxy inside of it it's
so cool
um so that's why yeah that's why i
wanted to do this
ah this is tough this is very tough it's
a very difficult
um material to create but we're almost
there i just want to get this
this look on the inside maybe it's me
just needing needing to mess
with our original let's try
hiding that duplicate and just trying to
mess with the original i wonder if it's
in roughness or maybe it's
in
what would make it look like there's
like stuff on the
inside of this thing
would it be transmission what if i gave
a bump map or a noise map to tran
transmission
octane noise let's give it a projection
and transform xyz to uvw for noise
always
it uh really spreads it out nicely
and we'll give it a contrast of 100
always
this is actually working for us you see
how
it looks like it's going like parts of
it looks like it's going
into it a little bit more but other
parts look like it's right on the
surface
that's exactly what we want
so let me try upping this the omega to
point
eight maybe to one
and octaves to eight
10 perhaps
and the contrast we can bring down to
like
20. that actually looks like there's
something in there it's pretty cool
let's take the noise and
basically want like little chips maybe
we set it the chips
and we invert it
contrast 100 let's just kind of take
this back or we could even do
circular
eight and point nine
dude mr hans hauser bosh
ridiculous killing it dude you're
breathtaking what the heck
my god this guy is
popping off that's like
250 this is the this is like 250 bucks
dude what the heck maybe even more
that's
you dude you're insane
thank you sir thank you sir
i got a full screen for that thank you
thank you you're killing it
what the heck never had it like this
that's crazy man
thank you so much
wow buy a zen garden now yeah dude
totally
that's so sick dude thank you so much
man
um let's un oh yeah this is what we want
this is exactly what we want look at
that
let's take the gamma either up or down
yeah okay maybe
yeah let's take the let's scale it down
0.2
so we get these little chips
that you only really see when the light
gets turned on so let's um
turn that off there you're only seeing
it when the light gets
turned on
but you are seeing it here so
how would that work it's very intense
maybe it's just like
the contrast needs to come down
and we need to change the color of it so
let's give it an octane gradient
and if we let's just change it to one
color let's see what it looks like as
one color
we set it to like uh actually no we need
it we need black and white we need both
johann johan one of those is probably
correct
thank you dude that's awesome man much
appreciated for that super chat
no text necessary huh just straight up
uh
helping your boy out man i appreciate it
thank you thank you so much
freaking awesome and we're getting that
look dude it looks like there's
something in there
let's let's keep messing with it i think
the contrast
um we need to i want to have more of
them
i want to have more of them so maybe
it's the gamma going up to like 1.5
but you see how that's it's not broken
up enough so the
omega needs to go to 1 octaves to 10
and maybe we crunch this
a little bit and render regions so we
can just
work faster crank the black up
crank the white we really get like some
specs in there and let's take
the transform to 0.1
so we have a little bit more of those
things
it's more detailed and let's see if we
can't adjust the color oh my goodness
mr hans hauser bosh
setting records dude my god everyone
friggin shout outs to this guy what the
heck man you're crazy
he says you have to study for finals now
go go study dude what are you even doing
um but thank you for the awesome content
keep being awesome
keep rocking that haircut got you and
hope you have a great weekend
you are killing it guys shout outs for
this guy man
seriously thank you so much mr hans
howser bosh
uh you have single-handedly
set the record for the most super chats
ever in a live stream
you're the best i hope to see you next
week dude that's crazy people are losing
their minds up in here
yeah seriously my god
william i don't think he knows the
difference between a chat in a super
chat
crazy freaking nuts
wow man this is this is i mean i i want
to have like party poppers for this like
just a string i pull and it all
comes raining down or something that's
awesome man thank you
hans you're amazing very generous person
seriously that's insane
um rock on dude study for those finals
knock it out
um i'm i'm floored thank you so much
you're the best dang
that's crazy huh guys
saigenius thank you as well thank you
for the super chat man you're great
they make the center concave from the
bottom like the real one
oh i could but i don't know if it helped
us too much
let's get back into it we got the look
of it here you know we got the look of
it looking pretty nice right here
let me see though if i can't take this
black
to a
uh like a light gray or something so
it's a little bit more
subtle in there it's just breaking that
up nice what if i take the white
down to a gray okay we don't want that
we want that to be fully white
but this gray maybe we take to a
red brownish red will that change the
color
let's find out if we go blue will it
look blue
it will okay good so that means we can
take it to
a brownish red orangish
color a dark red something like
something like that so you're seeing
these
little specks from the inside there
and if we turn off the light hopefully
they're not
too recognizable yeah they kind of
reveal themselves as the light gets
turned on you really see them when the
light gets
turned on the last thing i want to do
here
to wrap this out is have this white
crystal crust layer
kind of turn dark when the light turns
on you see how they just kind of go
invisible
i want them to turn dark so
how are we gonna do this
um
i think here let me actually let me real
real quick before we do that
let me throw in a multiply and a
float node to control the intensity of
this transmission here if i set it to
one
it looks about the same if i set it to
zero it should be gone
nope okay it's doing something we don't
want it to do we can just delete that
and i'll just take this closer to a
white i guess
yeah so we get some pieces in there
like red pieces on the inside
and we can take the light and turn up
the intensity maybe a thousand
way like i gotta react to the donations
man
i got to you know be rude not to
um and they catch my eye certainly
when i see him over here on the side
you know can't answer all the questions
god i gotta it'd be rude to ignore the
super chats that's for sure
um but i see it what am i what am i
doing with the money i don't know
i'll probably get a nice dinner with my
fiance and
maybe buy a an office chair or something
we'll see
anthony one hello for you what's up my
guy good to see you
thanks for joining
um have i heard of aces yes i've heard
of aces i don't really use it
ace is linear not really doing anything
right now for me
um i do i do use it sometimes but not
all the times i need i need to like
get it get used to it here in my
workflow um
what uh was i going to do let's try one
last thing
let's try another noise node let's bring
it down here
let's pipe it into the transmission
and let's see if we can't get some
streaky
things going here i want some like side
streaks
maybe we take the transform we unhook
those we go
10 and 10 and we go 0.1 to make it like
really streaky
which you get in these in these rocks
here and let's take
that and scale it up
and rotate it like 30 degrees
one of these will work i promise there
you go
yeah and then i want to give it um i i
only want this to be visible in the
center and not the sides
so for that i'm going to use a falloff
node this is when we're getting in our
uncharted
waters here fall off that's going to
basically say
you know what's ever on the outside is
going to be
visible and whatever's on the inside is
not going to be visible
but for us we want
let's see let's mix this with the
multiply
pipe that in we'll pipe the falloff in
and
type that in transmission and we'll see
what it does
not doing what we want so let's invert
the fall off
by changing these two guys
is that doing what we want no it's doing
the opposite of what we want
um so
maybe what i need to do is
switch that up maybe it's an ad is it an
ad
we're adding the noise and the fall off
together
into the transmission no that's not
doing it either
i want it to be invisible on the sides
do we invert
the noise
um no that's not doing it for us
let's see
hmm
this is a tricky one huh
looks like it's taking it away in the
middle but i think that's just by
default that's what it looks like by
default
um let's try taking those up to a
thousand
yeah that's what it looks more like that
in the rock salt lamp it's more like
streaky like that
um so you guys are saying have you tried
davinci resolve i love da vinci it's the
best
and i've been texturing for a while says
ricardo
i would love to get into modeling what
program would you recommend i start with
um whatever you want honestly like if
you already
you don't have a 3d modeling program
then blender is certainly free so it's a
good way to jump in
um but if you're messing with textures
maybe you're in a program that already
does 3d modeling so
give it a shot yeah give it a shot try
blender it's free
there's a lot of good tutorials for it
otherwise i love c4d or honestly
no stop don't listen to me listen to
this part um
fusion 360. get fusion 360. learn that
you're going to model easily in fusion
360
and it's free as well so fusion 360.
that's what you want
okay so i only want this visible
in the center only in the center
so i have to invert this
but it's not doing what i want it to do
um
maybe i
uh
let's try a gradient an octane gradient
and let's go ahead and crunch it
that's only visible in the center okay
really only visible in the center yeah
and then it kind of falls off
now if i switch these this goes to white
and this goes to black will it do what
we want
um kind of kind of yeah
i'll crunch that in it's only visible
from the center
maybe this white comes down to like a
gray
or something and then let's see if we
can't multiply this
one and then this noise node goes in
there and we go to the transmission
still janky why everything's i feel like
everything's backwards and upside down
try flipping them that doesn't work
either
maybe an ad node could work
did that work i feel like it kind of
worked
change this to white
where are those streaks at is this the
opposite of what i want
do i switch this back again
there we go my goodness finally
so it's not on the edges but it's in the
center
and it looks good let's take this white
down to a light gray
so that those are just visible
barely barely visible cool and we want
to combine these
so here's what i'm doing this is what i
did i use a falloff node
and a gradient to crunch it down and
then i used an add
to mix that uh streaky noise with it so
it's only being seen in the center
and let me take that back up to a white
cool and then let's go ahead and mix
these together and i think it's going to
be with a multiply node so i want the
stars
and the streaks together
so let's try a multiply node see if this
works
and it does it does yes it does
awesome that's super cool
i dig it it looks really nice
um we can take the contrast down to 10.
really subtle on those streaks there
and um the last thing i wanted to do was
try and get the
like white crystal to turn dark when we
turn the light on
for whatever reason the white crystal is
kind of like
disappearing let's see if i can't hop
back out
save my stuff that looks crazy
and we can delete that we don't need
that that's looking really cool
i want to take my roughness up a little
bit too probably
and maybe just kind of skinny up this
rock a little bit
and maybe even adjust
the shape of this
scale all this down towards itself
do something like that maybe
looks pretty darn cool
and we can scale the light down a touch
and maybe just
our that's a lot huh going into the
transmission
let's adjust the medium
over here maybe
maybe it's a little saturated here this
dark
one is a little bit saturated so i'll
make it a little bit brighter
and we'll take the
roughness
and i'm just gonna i'm probably gonna
just lose this
and mess with the roughness um
on its own here let's crank it
that's pretty freaking cool
i like that a lot let's let's give it a
uh
a little look here we'll go portrait 400
and
take that down that looks awesome
very cool i'm really happy with that
um let me rotate the environment around
it's kind of backlit that's really sweet
that's great yeah i'm really i'm a big
fan
um
how do we get the little crystal layers
to turn dark that's the last thing
i'll try it i'll spend five minutes on
this
hmm
so my default okay
this is looking like this here
and if i plug in let's go to the albedo
and if we take it to black
it goes away for some reason it doesn't
change the color that's
so strange
well that looks pretty sweet
that looks pretty sweet so it's the
it's the fact that it's
it's glass
i might have to just do a mix material
in order to get this look
correct
let me let me try a mixed material
i think that might work right now this
is what we got
let's go ahead and save this
we'll store the render and then
let's go ahead and
make a what do we want to make
a glossy material let's make a glossy
material
and let's apply this glossy material
to our rock
and we want to give it the same um
the same displacement and the same
normal
okay
so we'll copy these two guys and paste
them
into our glossy material we're building
up a
second material so that we can use a
mixed material in order to get these
like these pieces
now why it is shining through i have no
idea and why it's acting differently and
looking differently i have no idea
so maybe
maybe we do it the other way maybe we
just copy
holding control our original material
and let's give it the same oh it's
because it doesn't have
the same properties all right yeah
so i'll control drag this material and
then just replace it
by dragging and dropping so now we
should have
this new material if we delete all this
stuff
we should just be left
i refresh it hopefully
yep there we go now we're good
now what i want to do is change this
to a glossy material so we'll go to
basic we'll change it to a glossy one
zoom in on here oh also
your black and white images change the
type to float and you'll save some vram
so it's using it as a color but it's
just it's it's black and white so you
don't need it
now from here let's go ahead and
really boost up the
the index let's set it to like five
and let's do
what if we set it to one it's just
chrome
that doesn't look right so maybe it's
just like two or something so it's a
little bit more reflective than your
average
glossy material
and let's change the diffuse color
why is it white but when it's set to
black i don't understand
rgb rgb
spectrum we'll change it to a what if we
change it to black all right so it works
change it to an off it's kind of like a
grayish
now what we want to do is combine these
two with a mixed material so let's do
a new mix material we'll open this up
i'll draw drag in this material we just
made by holding shift
i can move the whole thing delete the
float texture
let's pipe this into material one and
material two
we'll drag into our scene as well
and let's just kind of drag this in
we'll pipe this into material
two and let's apply
this mix material
bam to our model
and we'll refresh our scene
see what we got okay so mix materials
don't
really apply the displacement so what
we'll need to do
is take this displacement layer here and
pipe it in
to the mix material itself
that okay that looks normal
i don't need to worry about this let's
just use the placement
displacement on the mixed material now
we're almost there let's take this
albedo setup
with the dirt node and everything let's
take this
and instead of piping it into this
rock texture let's pipe it in to the
amount
on the mix material and if i'm lucky
it'll do exactly the effect i want
and it will actually darken up those
crystal spots
when the light is turned on
what the heck okay
uh
huh
let's keep it simple let's just try the
dirt node and it looks like it's not
doing anything
um
let's solo the node
interesting
let me make a brand new one
a new dirt node just so that we have a
base
make sure that we don't like have any
issues they're carrying over from the
old one we'll set the strength to 10
we'll set the radius to 2.
we will let's see
distribution spread what do we want
details
we want to take this dirt node let's see
and uh
crank the spread crank the disc
distribution
why is it not working
interesting
sometimes i just like to refresh octane
to make sure it's working properly
why is it not black and white it's just
it's gray
um let's throw an octane gradient into
it
and see if we can't boost those colors
so strange
i don't get it do i need to reverse
these
textures material one
material two
no i'm not on an old material i have it
applied
it's definitely applied here
hmm
oh wait a second
oh it looks like i need
i need um
let's see albedo there we go
there we go okay
right now looks exactly the same which
is totally fine
but why is it just i don't understand
why that dirt note is like not
crank this
it's just acting very strange i think
it's because of the displacement map
on the actual it's working off the
displacement map
there we go so you see how it's
darkening up
these areas here instead of making them
invisible
does that make sense to you guys you see
how like when the light is on
it's darkening up these bits
on the on the like dark side of it
but it's just a little heavy so i think
what we
can do
let's take the gradient down
and instead of black it's like a dark
gray yeah you see how it gets it
gets that a little bit in there cool
so we take that into the multiply here
so it's not being applied to the whole
thing
um try
try that into the amount
hmm
very interesting
you know it was it was fine as is
but we're not we're in uncharted waters
so hopefully this isn't too boring for
y'all because this is just me
problem solving at this point
um
all right bonsai i see you
thank you for the super chat you're
saying are there any tips for staying
fit while having uh a profession which
requires you to sit in one place for a
long period of time absolutely man
yoga freaking love yoga i love getting
out and rock climbing i'm a drummer as
well
um and i love to run as well so
those are all good things that i enjoy
doing that help me personally
but yoga is very important it gets the
blood flowing
and it gets uh you know the healing
blood to all the right places
i actually am a certified yoga teacher
do you guys know that
i bet you didn't yeah uh
i am certified in yin yoga which is like
the slow moving
deep stretch kind of yoga i love it
it helps me a lot and thomas i see you
too man
you say i feel like the shader seems to
always be one note away from becoming
lava
yeah a little bit a little bit
but thank you for the super chat man i
appreciate you
ah this one's tough this one is very
tough
i feel like we basically had it on the
last one let me let me check my
reference video
um
let's see if i can't see my reference
video and
and see if this worked out um renders
i mean it looks good
looks really good
maybe i'm just saying that i don't know
i'll give it one last
looks really solid and i think we
i think it looks even better now that we
did that like uh
diffusion stuff but man this one's
really stumping me i don't know why it's
not working properly
maybe i have to invert this noise if i
want that to work properly
like that's the look for sure
caesar lg hey stick around man
stick around i promise it'll be worth
it'll be worth
uh i see you though thank you for the
super chat
uh let me say you always are inspiring
me every week
and i've learned so much man that's
awesome dude heck yeah
heck yeah yeah we're gonna review this
art in like 10 minutes
i promise
oh man that's i mean that feels pretty
darn good to me it's just the
light side now is like a little much
mssr media thank you for the super chat
you guys are freaking great today thank
you so much
um you don't know much about advanced 3d
shaders but this material looks sick
dude yeah heck yeah thank you
i'm really proud of it i'm happy with
how it's turning out i just
feel like um
it's a little it's a little much on the
on this side here it's a little too
a little too bright i turn
off this light yeah you just see there's
too much of it going on
and i think i just need to oh my god
hans mr hans is back
geez dude um yeah maybe maybe i'll do a
yoga stream
probably not but maybe i'll start a
channel where i just do yoga
videos who knows
mr hans i thought you were i thought you
were uh
studying for your your class dude yeah i
thought he was gonna study
freaking crazy man he's back
thank you so much that's amazing
all right we're almost done here we are
almost done
man we are almost finished i just need
to
i need to chill out this dirt map a
little bit it's crazy
that feels a little better maybe the
strength can come down
and the distribution maybe can come down
in the spread
you see i feel like the spread is
necessary because that
that just looks better straight up that
just looks nicer
um
the radius yes
it's the radius 0.25 maybe
and perhaps instead of a diffuse
maybe it is a
specular
as well here yeah and then the let's see
the roughness
maybe comes to zero
uh maybe not zero maybe it comes up a
little bit
but that is not that is not half bad
let's take that roughness up a little
bit more so it's not really reflective
awesome
that is not bad that is not bad at all
maybe let's see
yeah mixing some noise into it would be
nice so that not all the peaks are white
i agree that's what i was trying to do
up here
so let's see if i can't
do that as a last final step
all right let's grab some noise here
let's do
a little bit of octane noise
and we'll set the contrast to
100 and
let's bust out some projection
we'll set this to xy xyz to uvw
and the transform let's scale it down
but let's just see if this works for us
for a second um
let's do
let's see yeah maybe let's take this
down to 0.5 or something
and then use a multiply node to see if
we can't get this to work so let's pipe
texture that dirt node into texture too
let's pipe that into the amount
and that looks like it's not working
yeah we want to do maybe it's an ad
maybe we need to add it
there we go see that's taking away the
chunks now
so now we just need to you know work on
this
piece so it's working properly for us
um on solo patrick thank you
thank you for the super chat
um totally not appropriate but thank you
for the super chat
um uh gtj
yo thank you sir very very appreciative
of you man
um keep killing it i will we're almost
done here i'm gonna knock this one out
it's looking really good
so we just need to dial this piece in
here
let's take this up to like point nine
and we'll take the scale down to 0.1
maybe
nah that's too much let's go
let's go eight um on
that and we'll go omega point eight and
the scale
i think needs to come back up to 0.5
0.35 maybe
yeah maybe something like that and then
let's try inverting it
and let's let's see what that looks like
all right and
maybe as a final tweak
let's adjust the color a little bit it's
a little on the red side
and i want to get more to the orange
pink
side of things so let's do
let's see here wow that's really
stretched out why is it so stretched
one thing you can do is select all this
stuff right click and hit
auto arrange selected and that'll
that'll group things up a little bit
easier for us and we can hit
shift and pick up these little pieces
totally looks like steak now yeah it
definitely looks like steak
uh mr hans again dude
my god
geez man we are we are at 744 dollars
that is huge that is an all-time high
absolutely amazing um so mr hans you say
my girlfriend wants to get into cgi
we want to do weekly challenges
ourselves to improve our skills what
advice can you give for beginners
he's watching uh this with me by the way
okay so
i mean if you're part of my discord
server then you would know that there's
weekly challenges every single week
and the probably the
the easiest way to get in this is for
everybody if you guys are on a budget
i always recommend blender because it's
free
but if you if you have a budget a small
budget
then i love c4d it's my personal
preference i stream with it every single
week so
you could either look into blender
download it for free see how you feel
and if you're feeling good and you would
like to
make an investment into another program
then i'd have to recommend c4d it's
great i love it otherwise you know keep
going with blender whatever works for
you but those are two that you guys
should look into
and join the weekly challenges there's
endless tutorials on my channel
and the internet in general right so
uh the weekly challenges are a really
good way to stay consistent with things
and it's kind of based on the person
based off of preference how you wanna
how much you wanna dive into things you
can make it as difficult on yourself as
you like or
you know just tackle a small little
thing
but yeah again thank you for that super
chat you're killing it dude
okay so we have this like little meat
steak thing
very interesting material um
what were we doing we were adjusting
the heck we're readjusting we're
basically finished with this thing
um and why is it look like why does it
look like a steak
ah the displacement disappeared maybe
we undo that
oh we were messing with the color okay
so let's come in here and let's just
change this maybe more to
uh orangish
kind of a look
especially here
not as saturated
bring down some of that saturation
and it needs to be a it still needs to
be a bit more
pink so maybe we bring up this
brightness on that and maybe go more
towards the orange
it's not bad and what does it look like
with a light
oh no what happened
oh it's because of the
it's because we changed it to
a uh we changed this to
a uh uh sorry
i start to lose my mind by the end of
this thing we changed it to a specular
material let's just change it
to a glossy material
and that'll be a bit more on target
there
on the back side of this thing that
feels pretty good to me
maybe we take the diffuse of this down
just a little bit
so we do an rgb spectrum to a like a
light gray
maybe we give it a little color
just a little bit
and that looks pretty cool to me um
maybe we can take down this little
streak in here just a little bit
it's a little intense so i think that
streak is
what's working that streak
john yo thank you thank you man thank
you
uh i like to keep it up a little keep it
up emoji thing
that's cool thanks man i appreciate it
we're right at the end here this is
looking really good to me
i'm feeling good with this and then
we're going to get into the art review
thank you guys for
sticking with me for so long we've had
530 people
um popping off with us here
uh and johannes
i think johannes johannes smidberg
thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you man
very generous of you so he says a bit
out of nowhere would be cool seeing you
do a wallpaper engine background
combining uh techniques you have learned
love your stuff a wallpaper engine
background that'd be pretty sweet um
very sweet i love me some good
wallpapers so that would be a fun one
um frozen cheetah and john y'all are
killing it
guys thank you so much this stream is
the craziest stream i've done ever
the super chats are killing it today um
so frozen you mentioned rock climbing
what's your highest grade you've scaled
uh
jackie chan stuntmen react let's go yeah
let's get them on there dude
so yeah the first i've got was a v7 um
for bouldering
and then for top roping i
think like a 5 12
a i don't know a
is harder or d is harder
5 11 like the hardest 511 i've done
and i think one of the easiest the
easiest 512s i've done um
basically i don't know i freaking love
rock climbing it's great
outdoor ropes is the best i hope to go
uh
next week i think on friday i'm gonna go
with a friend here and with my buddy
cliff
who is working in blender he pops on the
stream sometimes
but let's rap it out let's wrap it out
and get into this
look how good this looks i'm really
happy with it i just want to take down
the intensity of that streak that's it
that's the last thing i want to do
so that's going to be
probably in here what if i take that
black to a light gray
no yes
perfect perfect perfect
so i only want to see it when you turn
on the light
but yeah it's
i don't know if we can get that far it
looks really nice with that light it
feels super cool
and maybe we can like give this thing
some cuts
let's see if we can't do like uh
edge loops on this thing i don't know
why it's uh it's looking like it's
looking can i get this
yeah like a cut there sharpen it up a
little bit
maybe a cut there to sharpen it up there
same for the bottom piece
and you can you know just change the
shape of this however you guys want
and this is our rock it's looking really
good
i think it's better than uh when we
started the stream
so if i were to pull up the reference
for y'all
where we started and where we left off
um
like this still looks really good um you
know pop it in the background it looks
amazing
but i think this one here has a bit more
detail in the center that i really enjoy
i hope you guys are able to follow along
with me and make some cool stuff
if we wanted to pop this thing onto a
background
it's very simple all i'm gonna be doing
here is just uh
you know doing a little grayscale
gorilla psych
here and we'll scale that down and
let's wrap it around here
and get rid of our render
and let's maybe center this thing up a
little bit
looks really cool and i know it looks
like it's floating here on the
actually floating could be really cool
a little floating rock
and then yeah i'm just using like a
grayscale gorilla plus library this
thing's the freaking best
and i'll just type in cloth
and grab this red cloth they have i'll
drop it onto that psych
and change it to whatever color you want
in this case
let me see if i can wrap this hdri
around
this looks so good i'm really happy with
how this turned out
and we'll just change this to a blue
because i think it goes well with this
background here
um but oh by the way here's a good tip
if you guys can't see anything in node
view just go to view and then hit frame
all
and it'll show your stuff and i'll just
do a little rgb spectrum in here
and we can change this to whatever color
we want so like a blue or something
um john and me be man
you guys are awesome thank you for the
super chats
so cool so freaking cool so john says
can't wait for the day we get to see
your movie all the experiences you guys
throughout the years looking forward to
that big milestone you're definitely an
inspiration for 3d artists man thank you
so much
i'm excited for my movie and it's going
to be so cool i cannot
wait to show you guys where it's just
going to be tough like
writing the thing and then getting it
funded that's going to be the hardest
part
obviously making the movies gonna be
really difficult too movie making is
some of the hardest
i mean just making short films right
speaking from experience on the short
film side of things
it is some of the hardest work i've ever
done
it's very laborious long hours
a lot of stress and um
but in the end it pays off it definitely
pays off
for me the more i put into my short
films in this case my movie moving
forward
the more satisfying it is to watch it in
the end like all of that hard work is
boiled down
to one movie and it's it's the best
me be man thank you you're awesome i
love you appreciate it
and hans houser once dude
you're you're just you're just dropping
these things like it's nothing man
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much
um you're blowing my mind here
you say it looks impressive the other
account
won't let you super chat anymore oh my
god
that's crazy you've been cut off dude
straight up
cut off that's insane thank you so much
sir i appreciate you very very much
um yeah this thing looks great doesn't
it i'm very happy with how this turned
out
maybe we can give it some
post-processing a little bit of glow
um crank the glare power on it and get
that cut off going so just at the source
there's a nice little glow in there
that's pretty cool
we can change the color of the floor to
a yellow if we want
you know fun color like that but it's
not really contrasting well
maybe it's like a minty green or
something um
that's kind of cool but i dig the blue
look
i wonder if maybe like a purple could be
cool
yeah that's pretty sweet
i really think that's cool yeah it looks
really good
okay so let's go ahead
and uh and render this thing
and move it up a little bit and just
have it floating and hovering
on this i'm not going to
i'm not going to render it here on the
stream obviously because that's going to
take time
but make sure when you animate your
light
or your your crystal here put the
crystal and the light in a null object
together
that way when you move it up and down
the light tracks with it
and it looks really nice
cool all right guys so we're
basically at the point here where we've
completed
our material and pretty soon here i'm
going to have a way for you guys to
download all this stuff for free
you can just take these materials and do
whatever you want with them pretty soon
i'm working on it there's a lot of a lot
of plans a lot of things i got to do
here
um but i want to get that going for you
guys
um but yeah i think it's time for a
little art review if you guys want to
see
some of the best renders from this
week's weekly challenge
then stick around i'm going to just take
a two minute break
grab some water um maybe a cookie
come back here and we're gonna take a
look at the best five renders from the
steampunk challenge
it's gonna be awesome and i got some
honorable mentions to show you guys as
well
so um bear with me i will be back in
like
two minutes don't move your butts hans
i don't know what to say anymore dude
you are
you're crazy you're crazy thank you so
much for all these super chats
you're making my day here i'm getting a
new chair
because of you thank you thank you so
much
see you guys in a second peace two
minutes
so
do
all right y'all we're jumping into it
all right we're doing the art review
okay hans is off his rocker
um he he's popping off right now
i appreciate you um freaking crazy
so i hope you guys enjoy these these
pieces of art here
it was a really cool challenge we had
like 156
submissions this week so freaking cool
you guys are blowing my minds
um and you're you're doing cool stuff
constantly so keep up the good work we
got some new winners here
this week who have not won a weekly
challenge
and of course we have some people who
have won in you know
who've won in the past um but regardless
all of them are fantastic renders so if
you guys win the challenge this week
you know as you know you guys are going
to be uh awarded with the challenge
winner role in discord
so you're going to be up on the top
right people see you they know that
you're winning challenges
and that you're doing good work so it's
just a little small reward for you guys
so let's um let's just hop in with the
first one here
right off the bat here we go bam cesar
lg
congratulations i told you to stick
around i told you'd be worth it
you're killing it man you're freaking
killing it this is really well done your
rendering quality
is fantastic um your lighting is really
nice
your textures are incredible there's
like a little dust and particulate in
the air
you got a nice little film grain on it
and stuff and some fog
dude you're hitting firing on all
cylinders on this one man
congratulations
you deserve it john also i see you thank
you for that super chat it means a lot
we're at an all-time high with super
chats on this stream
and you guys are amazing thank you so
much but yeah i love the save for a
later note on the spine i think that's
really cool
um and you i love the gear on the skull
here with the mohawk going
um really really sick really nice and
it's subtle it's a subtle steampunk vibe
i like that you did that
i think it's really cool um melanie yo
good to see ya thank you thank you for
the super chat i hope you're doing
better
i hope your day is going all right you
say you're a bit late to the stream but
i'm sure it's been amazing so far it has
been amazing
it has been a crazy one like lots of
support from people
on the stream here and we made some
really cool stuff
let me show you actually really quick um
made this rock salt lamp
and it looks so good i'm so happy with
how it turned out so i'm gonna model
that and uh or
animate it and post it up on the discord
maybe maybe on my instagram or something
um but let's yeah let's get back to that
review so caesar lg you're winning that
discord
challenge winner server role all right
your name's gonna be up in lights it'll
be up in there
so congratulations to you brother maybe
you're not here
maybe you're not in the stream anymore
but you'll definitely know in due time
you will know
so who do we got next um who do we got
next let's figure that out it's a good
question
bam one dead duck
you know you're putting out work that is
solid constantly
um oh we got casey edwards up in the
house
what's up casey good to see you we're
gonna drop something off for you a
little later today
all right um good to see you man but
yeah one dead duck putting out solid
work
totally reminds me of some like bioshock
um
i love it i think it's really good your
rendering is always solid
your characters are really really well
done here um and i love
i love all the detail that went into
this like the gauge on her chest
and uh like the barcode tattoo super
creepy
and the like the thing in her cheek is
disgusting
but you did some really solid work here
very well done
and very deserving of the challenge
winner role that you will get for this
week
hang on to it all right so your name
will stay up there
on the discord server all right what
else do we got
what else do we got number three boom
here zettle which i learned was mr
zettle
from uh from cliff he took german class
this one makes me laugh dude um i love
it
like it's a great render it's really
funny
and yeah it's just a goofy time
i love the volumetric smoke sim you got
up there coming out the back
it's really funny i like it a lot you
got some subtle animation of the
character
it's good man really really funny stuff
so congratulations mr zeddle you're
going to win
the challenge winner roll this week get
your name up in the lights
on the discord server keep it up keep
doing your thing i see your renders
they're really good
right um what do we got next
we got two more for you guys two more
winners
last but not least no this isn't last
second to last but not least
is yah cg md
not yah cg mod it's it's ya cgmd
um i've been saying it wrong this whole
time
look at how look how crazy this is it's
all from scratch isn't that unbelievable
the rendering quality is insane um
the only thing that i could nitpick
is the smoke you know if it was just
volumetric smoke that'd be amazing
but that's that's getting into the weeds
like this is incredible isn't it
absolutely beautiful um elrie talents
thank you for the super chat i
appreciate you
you say that you're working with a
character character skin but the color
comes
from a matte of low-res png how crazy is
it to sign colors with that
let me see if i can make sense of this
you're working with a character with
character skin
but the color comes from a matte of
low-res png
of a low-rise png how crazy
is it to assign colors with that well
maybe try uh
maybe try just like an rgb spectrum or
just like a texture color or something
if it looks good it looks good you know
that's the end of the day if it looks
good it looks good
but anyway y'all cgmd congratulations to
you man this is an insane render you're
getting better and better
like you came out of the woodwork like a
few months ago and just
winning these challenges man left and
right your stuff is so good
i really appreciate you keep doing good
stuff keep helping the community
and uh keep putting on these good
renders yeah
it's on a crazy level this week it
really is now this next one for you guys
very very happy this person won but i
have to preface that
um if you guys have
what is it you don't want to get a
seizure all right if you don't want to
get a seizure just bear with me on this
one
because it's a little back and forth you
know there's there's some lights popping
off so get ready hang on your butts
because noodle chon
is the winner the final winner with this
video here
i love this one yup darian said it
this is great i love the samurai
with the steam coming out like it's so
cool look how cool that is
so sick i love it
noodle john congratulations you deserve
it this week man
killer work very killer work absolutely
amazing
all right one more time watch yourself
watch your eyes you guys get seizures
hang on your butts
it cools off towards the end when you
see the final
but yeah man this is amazing i love it
really good work by noodle i love the
character really good uh
good character art here
super cool congratulations noodletron
and to the rest of you all who have won
this challenge
um you guys are getting the challenge
winner roll this week
on the server the link is in the
description
y'all are amazing and before we call it
quits
i got about 10 honorable mentions i want
to get into because
you know as usual you guys are doing
solid stuff and you're very close if
you've made the challenge winner
or i'm sorry if you made the honorable
mentions
that means you were in consideration for
the
the the top five okay
and if you're not in the honorable
mentions keep it up you'll get there i
promise just keep working on your stuff
um
but let's take a couple let's take a
look at some of these
this one here is absolutely beautiful
and it reminds me of
a video game called
dishonored is one of my favorite games
and i really enjoy it
yeah this one was very close to winning
very very close to winning
um you know it's tough with the camera
moves because
you got to move that camera in the
perfect way i think your first shot is
perfect your second shot i feel like
could pan over to a character on the
rooftop
right here pan over boom character on
the rooftop
that would have like really set set the
tone for me
going to the train close up on the train
i don't know i know that the focus is
the train
but maybe if you focus more on the
environment and like it's a tough one
it's a tough one to say like
it feels cinematic all the way to this
point right here
like the camera movement is a little too
free
to be in like a movie kind of world
that's just personal preference okay
so don't worry about it i think your
render is awesome that's why you're the
first one on the honorable mentions
um next up we got aaron houskey with
this cool render
i like this one a lot um really creepy
looks like a watch
spider clock thingy i love it
it's really well done and it's animated
nicely i think you did a good job with
like the joints and the
ik going on and i think it looked really
really good so
keep it up you're you're getting there
you guys are getting close
we got trung trung
du young i don't know if i said that
right
this is a cool one that you know the
only one the only gripe i have about
this one is that uh
it's just like it's a little plain you
know i think it's just your background i
think you probably could have
went for a more interesting background
but
i love the design on this i really
really enjoy the design on this
and i think that the work that you put
in to create this dragonfly is really
cool so
um solid work on that absolutely solid
work on that rendering quality it's all
it's all great it's all perfect i just
think you need that background
maybe a little bit more intense depth of
field um and it would have taken over
the edge for me
um pars v3l
we got you with this like crazy brain
machine
i don't know what this is but it looks
really cool your rendering quality is
good
you got this brain in a case and um
yeah like i don't know this looks really
cool you did a really good job
creating this and putting this together
so congratulations for making the
honorable mentions i just wanted to
shout you out
uh kimmy kimmy yo this is a cool one i
like this character piece it kind of
reminds me of something visual would do
um you know visuals always putting out
really cool character stuff
with solid render quality and like this
feels like that to me
so this is really awesome i just wanted
to shout this out i think that your
character is a
is a really good one i like the design i
like the arm um
got a little story going on here with
this character so
shout outs to you um folio is next with
this
cool hammer i like your design i love
your rendering quality and your
background like just you integrated
everything perfectly
it looks really really good um i like
this one a lot
yeah your textures are solid literally
everything here
is solid and i like the steam coming out
of the hammer it's a really nice
touch that you've added i think it looks
really great
um bayou bongo is next with this jimmy
neutron
style render this one this one came
close i like this one a lot
like what you did here your rendering
quality is fantastic i assume you
downloaded the
the jimmy neutron model and um
maybe you modeled the dog that'd be
really cool
but really cool work here doing like a a
different take
on the show i thought that was really
awesome
well sorry we got zach 4k with a samurai
render
you know i love me some samurai stuff
this is really cool
um totally reminds me of like dishonored
2 when you sneak into the
to the like the big mansion party they
got some party going on then you got the
motorcycle on the left i feel like the
motorcycle could be a little bit more
involved
in the shot it's hard it's kind of like
just out of frame
cool stuff with the blimps i dig the
blimps um
and overall i like the vibe i think it's
really cool so
keep it up zach i see you man keep doing
your thing
all right what else do we got what else
do we got
trocco this one made me laugh dude this
is awesome i love the character
um i love the world that you put them in
the motion i feel everything like it
it looks it looks great i really like
this one man
see you guys are getting really close
with your stuff you're you're involving
story that's
that's the the secret sauce
is the story you want to include story
in your renders
um that's what sets people's renders
apart
from others sometimes it's just like an
object which hey don't don't get me
wrong stuff like um
stuff like this it's really really good
there's a little story
going on with the background with the
pictures on the wall um
or you know one like this
there's a story in the sense that like
it's interesting
but they're you know something like this
there's a
little bit more of a story going on
like i just have a lot of questions who
is this guy where what's he doing
um yeah it's interesting to me it's very
interesting so
not that those other renders were bad
because it didn't have story they could
just be better
given more story right that's that's
always the goal is to go with more
story all right we got nasa camera
next fantastic render quality again this
reminds me of like a visual style
piece um who puts out amazing characters
all the time
and your hair shader is incredible
absolutely incredible i just wish you'd
include a little bit more of the
character it's hard to see it looks like
just a head and a hand
um but it is cool because it looks like
someone who took the picture is trying
to sneak a shot because they're hiding
behind a lot of stuff
in the foreground um but i really liked
this one
it came very close to winning and if you
know just keep up keep it up keep doing
your thing
and you'll get there looks really good
we have three more
all right joshua rocks with this amazing
pocket watch render um
looks absolutely beautiful you know
just like all these other renders here
this one is
rendered perfectly lit perfectly um
you know it kind of eludes to
a bigger more interesting world i like
that a lot i wonder who owns this thing
i wonder what that key goes to
definitely has my interest peaked so
i think it's very good joshua congrats
for the honorable mention
keep doing your thing you're very close
bashal this one is this one is super
cool
um a really cool character
i dig it it's just not very like when i
see this i don't think it's steampunk
um so that's like one of the first thing
i check is does it
does it check off the challenge when i
look at this do i think steampunk
it's close you know it's close but it's
a little bit more like
princess mononoke a little bit maybe if
you were inspired by that let's go let's
go uh full screen on this thing
because there's a really cool thing that
you did here with the
like the fur and the hair on
like the side of this cloth
poking out catching the light really
nicely it looks super cool
very very solid work here so congrats
bashful that's a good one really good
one um
an armored cabbage finally with this
really really cool
um like gas mask kind of thing
very nice render quality very nice
design
very nice lighting and rendering you
should be very proud of yourself it
looks really good
yeah and that's it guys that's it for
the
challenge winners uh this week to
noodle and to mr
zettle and i'm really pushing myself to
memorize all these now
um yah cgmd and
uh a couple other people
congrats guys i appreciate it you guys
are awesome thanks for putting in all
the good work
so now this brings us to the point where
we're at the end of the stream and we
have to figure out
what the new challenge is for this week
okay
so what do you guys want to do for the
weekly challenge this week we got ideas
you know like we can we obviously did a
crystal thing
in in uh
in c4d and this is where i started
losing my mind here
because it's the end of uh it's the end
of a stream but
we got some stuff all right we got
geology that could be interesting
space i think we've have we done space i
feel like we've done space before
caesar yes thanks for the reminder
thanks for winning dude appreciate you
man
i'm glad that you're able to pop in here
and uh and see that you won
congratulations super cool
ah galaxy nega ooh negative space could
be very interesting
that'd be a good one on framing i like
that
um horror we did horror that was a
halloween one
uh japan man maybe not bad ian hubert's
style i don't know
ah maybe i want to have ian on maybe
we'll do it we'll do it then and he'll
he'll do it self-portrait oh okay so
that's what we did over at um
a corridor that was actually really cool
what do you guys think about a
self-portrait one yes or no
self-portrait challenge what do you guys
think
just give me a simple yes or no and we
can judge it based off of that
lots of no's why why too difficult
difficult for you guys um
interesting okay let's go back to the
suggestions here guys let's go back to
the suggestions
um do you guys like picking the weekly
challenge here
or would you prefer that i have just
like three options for you that you vote
on immediately
i'm i'm uh curious about that as well
so okay so back to it i like negative
space is pretty sweet
zen is a cool one down for that
um
zombies john i see you indiana jones
challenge
indiana jones could be interesting um
maybe like adventure or something so
it's a bit more
a bit more broad we could do adventure
we could do negative
space oh man chernobyl that'd be intense
hmm caesar tim burton would be cool
i see you i see you tim burton challenge
that would be pretty sweet we could do
tim
between tim burton negative space
and what was the one that you
recommended what was the tim burton
negative space
an adventure what do you guys think
about those three
tim burton negative space and adventure
i'm gonna start a straw poll really
quick i'm gonna start
a straw poll for you guys um
and see if we can't get this challenge
figured out
i like doing it here with you guys live
um
all right so we have for the weekly
challenge
we have negative space which would be a
really good
challenge on your framing and
composition
we have okay hold on
we have adventure which is a bit more
broad but i like it
um we have tim burton
and one
more one more
vikings
marvel okay visual yeah you called it
marvel
all right guys chill out on the
suggestions because i'm gonna post a
link for you guys right now
i want you to go here and i just want
you to vote okay um you got one vote
whichever one wins between these four
will be the weekly challenge
all right so ease up on the ease up on
the uh
suggestions so you guys can see my link
here and let me create this for you guys
really quick
let's create the poll and let's
share it we got a link for you guys
and go for that all right boom right
there go go to that link
and get your vote in
i'm gonna call it in one minute you have
one minute to get your vote in
50 seconds
seconds get your votes in guys you don't
see the link it's just up here it's just
up here in the chat
thanks darren appreciate you
your boy gabe man it's theirs or just
look up
i don't think you can pin can you pin
stuff in chat
pin message yes you can
all right is that it i'll give you guys
like 30 more seconds
hans freaking hans man
you're ridiculous we are literally
almost at a thousand dollars
that is insane we're eight dollars away
goodness goodness
you're crazy um the votes are in guys
we got 218 votes that's half of ya
so that means i hope to see 218
submissions
is that what you guys are telling me
all right um
225 it looks like i'm gonna go
go live here john thanks for pushing it
over the edge
holy crap 1k
uh in super chats that is unbelievable
i that's ridiculous thank you guys so
much
thank you thank you for making that a
thing i'm getting a chair
i'm getting my fiance a chair and we're
gonna go and get some steak or something
i appreciate you guys so much thank you
thank you
but the the jury has spoken
and it looks like
it's gonna be negative space
right you guys chose it negative space
um that means you just gotta google
negative space if you know what it is
now that's lame i'll tell you all right
so negative space is basically
what's the best uh let me just google it
i'll show you guys i'll give you an
example it's basically the
the space in an image you don't fill
um let's see negative space
cinematography negative space
cinematography
yeah all right let's let's show you guys
this
so you got some negative space here in
this image
this is all negative space all of this
area here is negative space
matthias yo thank you thank you sir
how about a little more absolutely man
you guys are awesome thank you so much
thank you so much absolutely incredible
here's more negative space for you this
is all negative space here
on the side sai charon thank you sir
thank you thank you sir yeah me too man
this is all negative space right your
focus is here
negative space on the side um
wow this is a beautiful image absolutely
beautiful image
all this is negative space this is all
negative space on the side
you guys are getting the idea right
negative space here in the back
um it's a really cool way to work with
your framing and come up with some cool
options that aren't you know textbook
here's another one negative space on the
back side
so really try and dig into it guys um do
a bit of little
little research on negative space you're
gonna you're probably gonna get a lot of
articles on cinematography
and whatnot dig into them learn about
the the
the camera angles that make something
look and feel a certain way
so that's what you guys should learn
here during this challenge obviously
you're gonna render
and create some cool stuff but really
this is
this is a composition challenge how do
you
place the objects in your scene in such
a way
to give a really cool feeling
and a cool framing to the objects and
the story that you want to tell to the
feeling you want to give off
right so we're getting into a little bit
of cinematography this week
which is great because i think a lot of
y'all including myself
need it all right the cooler your camera
angle
um the cooler everything else is you
know so instead of just popping a shot
i'm just like
boom center frame get get you know get
fancy with it have fun with it and do
something different so this will be a
good one for you guys
i'm excited william i know you're
excited i've seen some of your stuff man
you got a lot of that going on
um but y'all it's been a good one
i'm gonna bounce out of here um
maybe buy a chair or something we'll see
but you guys are amazing thank you so
much um
i'll take one minute one or two minutes
here i'll answer any questions you guys
have in like the next two or three
minutes
oh that's a good one i'm really happy
with uh
with this with this rock lamp here this
is super cool
i love it a lot um
i want to do a little render that'd be
sweet change the color maybe a little
bit
get like a nice blue going or something
that feels really good alright so just
hit me um do the at punisher thing here
so i can see your questions
bad apple is there any chance of
switching to blender nope no chance
sorry
i love c4d um well you try
paint 3d i don't know what paint 3d is
but
substance painter i want to get into
john thank you for the super chat i see
you man with the chair
that's great um mick how did i get
better at drawing
by drawing by drawing man i just draw
and draw and look up videos on youtube
lots of good stuff there's a guy named
um
shoot what is his name i forget his name
it's like how to do pen drawing
how to draw with a pen dude's amazing i
forget his name right now i'm i'm
blanking on i apologize but just keep
drawing draw draw draw
um let's see oh
shot deck is a good site to see movie
shots and filter by keyword thank you
good to know
try casting light onto the ground from
the rock okay i'll try that
should you invest in a good computer um
i don't know
would it help you on your creative
journey in the future would it allow you
to make more money
um for yourself
then maybe yeah i don't know or
you can try the vegan link in the
description
click that link in the description it
helps me out helps me get more sponsors
it's a good time makes them happy makes
me happy click the link
down below guys check out vegan it's
really cool
it's a cloud-based super computer if you
don't have a bunch of money to buy a
super computer
it's basically what it is um i
appreciate you guys thank you thank you
what else um can i stream
blender with peter i'll bring peter back
absolutely but i'm i probably won't be
in blender though i'll be in c4d
what's the story behind my name um great
question so
when i was in high school middle school
um
me and my friends we loved a show called
pure ownage
spelled pure pwnage it's the first web
series i ever seen
um it's the where the the term boom
headshot came from
fps doug good friend of mine he was in
carbo warfare 2.
um yeah those guys are all awesome pure
owners best show ever
and we had like a little wrestling after
school we'd get together and wrestle and
we all had names based on
you know the pwn kind of little handle a
little
name and uh one one guy was the grand
masterpone and then you had the ponerer
and then i was the punisher so that's
how i got that name
um are you looking for story creators i
don't know rendering but i'm into
writing stories and premises
right now i'm working with a writer on
my movie so currently
currently not but that doesn't mean
um i will never be so keep writing keep
you know pushing forward on your craft
and maybe in the future it'll be a place
for us to do something cool together
um will i sell the salt rock as an nft
for charity
i don't know i'm working on my next nft
right now it's going to be a bigger
environment scene
then i want to get that out pretty soon
maybe i'll do some salt rock thing
with like a with like the singing bowls
or something i don't know
we'll figure it out not quite sure
um he graduated from college with a film
degree i always said i wanted to be a
vfx artist should i focus on modeling
right now or do more composition and
element work like
energy stuff um you know that's really
up to you
let's see i lost your chat there for a
second huh um
where'd it go
lost your chat anyway yeah focus on
whatever you think that you need to get
better at that you enjoy when it comes
down to just enjoying
what you're doing okay um
if you're not enjoying what you're doing
then it's gonna be really hard to
continue doing it so
just for me i would focus on the
tutorials that i really loved doing
that's about all i can say you know like
you can also look at
what kind of things would be needed in
your field
like if you're trying to do simulations
or um
lighting rendering modeling all that
stuff comes to a point where like
you're gonna need to know how to do all
that stuff
but just focus on the little pieces that
you enjoy really follow that
you'll be good um what else do we got
uh super chat sai sharon thank you um
you say is there any good resources to
get better
with materials that helped you or is it
just by experience
so it's always an element
of just messing around with things
tinkering and seeing what does what
that's
that's the best way to learn but you do
that in conjunction with tutorials so
literally youtube anything you want is
gonna be there
um you guys know i do stuff with
skillshare um
so skillshare is also a great resource
to look up tutorials and stuff
if you want to get more of like a paid
thing doing a paid thing
um for me on cinema 4d
i love grayscale gorilla i love their
stuff so much i use it all the time
um then you also have guys like um
david raf octane jesus right he
back in the beginning he posted on i
design i like your eyeball
design i design um so i learned a lot of
octane
pretty much all through david um is how
i learned octane and stuff so
those are some good resources otherwise
just youtube it yeah there's a lot of
good stuff out there
what else what else so many questions
um might be all the time we have for
guys
can i stream with ian hubert yes i do i
do want to stream with ian hubert
um i just need to ask him first but i
think he'd say yes we'll have to see
we'll have to see
all right guys um i think this is that's
about it i gotta call it i gotta get
some lunch here
but i appreciate y'all you guys are
awesome thank you for the super chats
um what a what a day it's been that was
absolutely amazing guys thank you so
much thanks for sticking with me i hope
you guys learned something
i'm really proud of this little rock
that we came up with here i can't wait
to render it
gonna be awesome you guys have a
fantastic saturday have a good weekend
and i'll catch you guys live next week
on saturday okay have a good one y'all
peace out oh i'm not gonna end the
stream no we gotta hit it with the uh
with the outro
so
you